we have two tubes that are right next to
each other in the throat one is for food
drink saliva mucus snot whatever you're
gonna swallow
all of that stuff must go down the
esophagus the food tube and end up in
the stomach and right next to the
esophagus millimeters away
is the windpipe or the trachea which
goes down to the lungs throat heart
feces genitals every organ from moment
to moment keeps us alive and ensures our
survival the genitals are in a way the
opposite how would you improve
the penis and the vagina
the following is a conversation with
jonathan weissman a physician and writer
of the unseen body a doctor's journey
through the hidden wonders of human
anatomy he has practiced medicine in
some of the world's most remote places
including the alaskan and russian arctic
antarctica
and the himalayan mountains of nepal
this is alex friedman podcast to support
it please check out our sponsors in the
description and now to your friends
here's jonathan reisman
you wrote a book called unseen body
all about the human body the messy the
weird the beautiful and the fascinating
details
so from an evolutionary perspective are
most parts of the human body a feature
or a bug
is it
like the optimal solution or just a duct
tape solution great question i think
that
most of the time the way the body works
is the best solution
i haven't seen many alternatives so it's
hard to compare
but
i think you know there's some parts of
the body that make more sense than
others you know the way our hands work
for instance
um you know the muscles are up in the
forearm and then the tendons kind of
come down like strings on a puppet and
just the dexterity it gives our hands is
just really
amazing and it's hard to imagine a
better
a better tool than the human hand to do
everything from you know hold things to
play piano and do a million other daily
activities that we do
one thing i talk about in the book
there's some other body parts that seem
to be lacking that kind of brilliant
design such as the throat you know where
the
food drink are swallowed and air is
inhaled and they kind of those two paths
come within millimeters of each other
and you slip up once you laugh while
eating
or you speak while trying to swallow and
you die from choking so it seems less
than optimal though i'm not sure it
could be better from the way we're kind
of formed in the womb as a beginning as
this tiny little tube i don't think it
could have been done any better or
there's any other way to do it but it is
an unfortunate thing that
you know does lead to some problems so
the hand if i could just linger on that
for a second
you talk about the wisdom of a design
in the book
what are the important things about the
hand it seems like very
useful for many things and it seems to
be quite effective
a lot of people think the thumb
is foundational to um
to the human civilization
um is there any truth to that
i think that is true actually one of the
ways in which the importance of
individual fingers comes
to attention is when people have severe
injuries to their fingers for instance
um i have a story in the book about a
guy whose thumb is nearly ripped off by
his dog's leash
and you know when we when plastic
surgeons who are often the ones to
repair that sometimes it's orthopedic
surgeons they will debate you know how
important is it to save this finger or
how important is it to save you know
let's say the kind of
tip uh the one-third the tip one-third
of one of your fingers you know it
depends on the length that you'll lose
it depends on which finger and so the
thumb really is the most crucial um just
you know for your occupation in most
cases to
just daily life um and your ability to
get around take care of yourself and
others so
you know they'll be more they're willing
to go further do more surgeries more
aggressive therapy to save a thumb let's
say
than you know the tip of your pinky
finger so in that way i do think the
thumb you know does seem like the most
important in many ways it's nice that
there's backups i wonder if that's part
of the feature or is it just the
symmetry that nature produces you think
you think that two hands is like is it
about the symmetry or is it about backup
we'd be much less formidable hunters
gatherers
survivors in any way
if we only had one hand so i think
that is important to have two so we can
you know even everything from kind of
spearing an animal to firing a bow and
arrow to butchering an animal you really
need two hands to do it very effectively
but can you do a better job with three
great question
and we'll never know perhaps
um
you tweeted now i'm gonna analyze your
tweets like it's shakespeare sometimes
you tweeted that quote millions of years
of sex and death
designed the human body
it's like poetry
are those two basic activities
uh
basically summarize everything that
that resulted in humans on earth so like
uh is it is that a good summary
of the evolutionary process that led to
this conscious intelligent being is
death and sex
in a way yeah and so sex is how more of
us get made obviously and death is how
we get weeded out or the gene pool gets
weeded out and certain genes survive and
others don't and you know the age at
which we die
whether it's before we've you know had
sex and reproduced ourselves is a big
factor and who survives who doesn't who
passes on their genes and what the
future
of the body looks like you know who
lived and who died
before they were able to be at
reproductive age a million years ago was
pretty important in what we look like
now
um and perhaps
how we have sex and die now will
determine what we're shaped like
unless technology has an even bigger
role in that you know a million years
from now do you think that's fundamental
to like if there's alien civilizations
out there that have uh the same order of
magnitude of intelligence or greater do
you think that we will see something
like sex and something like death so the
reproducing
and this selection process plus the
weeding out
of the old to make room for the new is
that kind of
foundational to life i would think so i
mean it sure seems to be on earth you
know perhaps in some distant future when
medicine is nearing you know perfection
and people can live a really long time
uh maybe we won't even need to reproduce
as much
or something like that you know it's
hard to even know what
what life will be like in the distant
future but i would guess that any alien
civilization will have the same
dependence on who who has sex and who
dies well that's the problem with
immortality how are we going to clear
out
the old
to make room for the new which is as
kind of um
it's like a framework of adaptability to
changing environments so as long as the
environment is changing and it seems to
always be
because this the entirety of the earth
system is a complex system it seems like
you have to adapt and to adapt you have
to kill off the stubborn old
ideas
and uh unless there's a way to like not
become stubborn and old but it feels
like
the nature of wisdom
is stubborn and old like that's that's
what wisdom is it's like the lessons of
life solid the lessons of experience
solidified
and the solidification is the thing that
actually prevents you
from reinventing yourself
to adapt to the new
um
changing conditions but then again why
not have that both of those modes like i
have two minds and one person one
immortal person that like
in the morning they act like a teenager
in the evening they act like a old wise
man
that's possible so you can imagine
within one mind
both modes
but those are required you have to have
you have to have the ability to
completely reinvent yourself which is
what death does
in an ugly way
or a beautiful way depending on your
perspective depending whether you take
the human perspective of the human uh
the nature's perspective and then you
have to have the selection so
competition so sexual selection
it's an interesting interesting little
planet we got what's the weirdest part
function concept idea
about the human body to you we'll talk
about fascinating details but what's you
i should say for people that should uh
read your book they will come face to
face with the fact that you do not shy
away
from the weird and the wonderful of the
human body it's like
it's fun but it's honest
uh so given that
sorry to make you pick one of your
children but uh what's the weirdest one
would you say
the weirdest body part um or concept
or function
so the chapters you divide it up kind of
into parts
but
there could be a thread that connects
all of them the weirdness
maybe
or maybe the the texture of the
substance could be the liquids the
solids i don't know
definitely every body part and bodily
fluid has their own um kind of both
gross and fascinating aspects that's
probably why i'm a generalist as a
doctor and couldn't just as you said
pick one of my children become a
specialist because i like them all
um
i feel like one of the strangest
concepts about the human body is that
kind of the aspects of it that are the
most universal that we all do are the
most taboo socially um i wouldn't have
expected that if i had you know just
looked from the outside like what we do
in the bathroom what we do in the
bedroom
what we do to our
own genitals what we do to our uh you
know
quote-unquote private parts they're
private even though it's sort of the
thing that we have all have in common
um is the most we try to hide from other
people and don't talk about polite
company i mean it makes sense as a human
living in the society but from the
outside it sort of might be surprising
how do you make sense of that if you put
on your
sigmund freud hat
the thing we all do why do we make that
a taboo thing is it because we like
taboos maybe we get off or maybe our our
our our kinks as humans is to have
taboos and it's kind of efficient to
have taboos about the things that
everybody does
like you can make walking taboo or
something i don't know but just uh maybe
that's what we love that's what's
exciting to us is the is the forbidden
i think yes society loves rules for sure
they loves
some societies more than others you know
they love controlling how you think and
what you do in public versus private you
know there's a lot of societies where
for instance parents have sex in front
of children
um not you know for instance like in in
a traditional inupiat eskimo societies
that was sort of normal
i mean but what are you gonna do go
outside in the middle of the winter in
the arctic and do it out there of course
not so um you know there's different uh
different taboos in different societies
some taboos make perfect sense some
taboos are
even public health measures you know
like as i talk in the book about in in
india where they
uh you know the hands are symmetric as
you said but in indian culture and the
left hand is taboo and the right hand is
what you use for shaking hands
for eating for other things and the left
hand is
the dirty hand that you use for wiping
your own bottom you know that's the
toilet paper as your left hand so
um while the body is anatomically
symmetric the taboo creates this pretty
intense asymmetry uh but for a good
reason you know you probably shouldn't
be shaking hands with other people with
the same hand that you use to kind of
clean your bottom so in that sense it
makes sense
yeah maybe the roots of it make sense
but the way it propagates especially as
the times change might not because you
can wash your hands
but the the taboo remains right society
is very slow to change
what is the most fascinating part
function or concept in the human body
so
you know something that fills you with
awe
i guess the most obvious one is the
brain partly because it's so you know
sort of poorly understood that we
understood
understand more than we ever have in the
past there's still so much that we don't
understand about
how the lump of matter and our skulls
kind of creates this subjective
experience that we all kind of
understand quite viscerally
that's an easy one i would say the
kidneys are an underappreciated organ uh
they
the the way they tinker with the
bloodstream
raise levels of this lower levels of
that kind of our entire lives from
uh inside the womb until we die is just
really incredible and when you look at
how much energy different organs consume
the brain and the kidneys are two of the
biggest ones because the brain obviously
in us is always active and controlling
parts of the body but the kidneys are
just
consuming a ton of energy to do what
they do they're kind of the unsung hero
of the body relegated to the back of the
abdomen like some forgotten organ but
they're they are great i did consider
being a nephrologist which is a kidney
specialist because i was so taken with
the kidneys but you know decided i like
all the organs so couldn't pick just one
so your book is ordered in a particular
way it's
throat heart feces genitals liver
pineal gland
brain skin
urine fat
lungs eyes
mucus
fingers and toes and blood
alright
first of all great great uh chapter
titles
uh is there a reason for this ordering
or is it all madness
there's a few different reasons that
went into it um i did want to start with
the throat for
the reason that
it kind of presents uh the topic of
death which is sort of obviously very
important in the training of a physician
in the career physician it's a big part
of what i deal with you know on the
first day of medical school
we started the dissection of a cadaver
in the class called anatomy lab and so
in a way we were kind of thrown right in
there in the beginning like this is the
end of the human story you know
understand this and then we sort of
backed up to the beginning with
embryology and reproduction and stuff so
it's kind of like we got and i got
thrown into that
right right away right in the beginning
kind of like here's a dead body now
start cutting it apart and learn the
name and function of absolutely every
bit of flesh how did that change you
that first
experience with the cold honesty of
human biology all right that's exactly
what it was it's cold honesty about the
kind of the story of of each individual
human body it has an end and that's it
um i think that well
actually before the end of that first
day so what we did on that first day was
study the superficial muscles of the
back like the lats or latissimus dorsi
and some other muscles you know we cut
through the skin of the back my cadaver
was laying face down on this metal
gurney we pulled back the kind of
plastic sheets that would keep him moist
for the next four months as we dissected
him
cut through the skin on his back and
then started dissecting through the
superficial muscles of the back and that
was really all we saw that first day
we didn't get any deeper didn't enter
the abdominal or
chest cavity to see internal organs but
i was so fascinated with this sort of
behind the scenes look at how things
work in the body how you move your arms
how you arch your back you know these
are the muscles that do it
that i decided i wanted to donate my own
body for the same purpose um so i made
that decision literally before the end
of that first day of class and i i'm
still sticking to it
so someday there will be a medical
student
that can
watch and listen to this podcast and
while dissecting your body it could
happen they might not know that that
person they're listening to on the
podcast will be the carcass in front of
them but uh like we don't we never learn
the universe will know the universe and
they will acknowledge
the irony or the humor the absurdity of
that the universe will chuckle but the
medical student won't know
because they never as i did not learn
any uh you know personal information
about the person
only what i could glean from looking
inside him which actually tells you
quite a bit i knew he was a smoker i
knew he had coronary artery disease you
know you get a a window into i knew he
was overweight you get a window into
people's lives just by looking in there
in their bodies after death other other
um
cadavers in the lab not my own
or i shared one with three other
students but other cadavers some had you
know metal joints like a knee
replacement some had a kidney missing so
they probably and we could tell it was
surgically removed not that he was born
with one
uh and we could tell that he probably
had a kidney tumor or cancer that was
removed so you you do get an insight
into people's lives from
you know picking them apart after
they're dead uh but you don't know their
name or what podcast they've been on
so the as the book title says unseen
body
so it it tells
some kind of story of your life
so it does capture the decisions you've
made in your life the things you've done
that might be kind of secret
to that person and maybe to a few others
that knew
him or her well
it's so fascinating so
what kind of things can reveal like what
kind of choices in terms of the injuries
the
the the catastrophic events
the
lifestyle choices of smoking and diet
and all those kinds of things what what
what
what can you see what kind of history
can you see about the human before you
so all those things you mentioned are
things you can see you can you know take
the skin for example right most things
that happen to us
leave a mark uh you know as i say a kind
of a story written in the language of
scar where it tells you injuries you've
had and same thing with animals you know
i've
i've seen deer hides that have marks
that look like they're made by maybe a
barbed wire fence something like that
you can tell
you know you sometimes it's conjecture
but you can sort of imagine what might
have happened to cause that perhaps you
know two bucks were fighting and one got
injured with an antler um and the same
with humans you know i have scars on my
body and when i
notice them i remember what happened you
know i
got a big cut of my hand when i was 13
and it's still there and i
remember what happened uh you know every
time i look at it and so in that way
only i might know that story but other
people you know when they dissect me and
notice the same scars they can kind of
can fire their imagination as my cadaver
you know did for me they know that there
is a story there that's such an
interesting way that the skin does tell
a story
uh both tattoos and scars
some of the damage you've done right and
even when i when i evaluate a patient i
can use scars
to help me make medical decisions so for
instance someone that comes in with
abdominal pain into the emergency room
you can see scars on their abdomen that
tell you about you know the past kind of
activities of a surgeon perhaps i know i
recognize the scars that are left when
someone has their gallbladder removed
the scars when someone has their
appendix removed when maybe when
someone's had a hysterectomy and that
can tell you
what it might be or what it isn't you
know if someone doesn't have an appendix
their abdominal pain is not appendicitis
end of story so in that way
i'm sort of looking at these the the
tracks or the footprints of past
surgeries to tell me what what might and
might not be the cause of this patient's
abdominal pain which is kind of my main
job in the er is figuring out what's
causing it and to help them
is there
ways to get more data about the human
body as we look into the future of
medicine biology that would be helpful
to fill in some of the gaps of the story
so
you know you have
you have companies you have research
that looks at you know uh collection of
blood over long periods of time to see
sort of
you know paint the picture of what's
happening in your body mostly to help
with lifestyle decisions but
but also just you know to anticipate
things that can go wrong and all that
kind of stuff is there can you just
speak to
um
a greater digital world that we're
stepping in how that can help
tell a richer story
i certainly think that we
have more data than we know what to do
with right now especially with kind of
direct-to-consumer medical devices you
know smart watches etc that are just
collecting these reams of data i have
not seen them put to i think the
eventual use that they will
um i think that the
potential is is sort of just um you know
unimaginable and i hope we're heading
into a new age where you know you can
determine for instance is a person going
to have more of the dangerous side
effects to a drug based on their
genetics or are they going to tolerate
one drug better than the other you know
based on on their genetics and
we are slowly moving into that age and
especially the age of kind of completely
synthesizing drugs in a lab
um you know much like
for instance some of the covid vaccines
actually like moderna never had a vir
the virus in their lab they made that
vaccine completely without ever having
the virus themselves just by having the
genome which is sort of astounding and
there's a lot of potential going forward
you know based on that technology and
some others well i didn't know that so
they basically it's all in the computer
it's computational right you have the
genetic code you have tremendous power
even if you don't have the organism
itself
what do you make of elizabeth
holmes and efforts like that first of
all
i am
a
curious
i'm drawn
to the darkness in human nature because
that somehow reveals
um
the full spectrum of what humans could
be
so there's a lot of controversial
thoughts about who she is and her
efforts and so on
i think you may have even tweeted about
it but i've read a lot of your tweets so
i'm not forgetting um but what do you
make of her and those that both those
efforts and the charlatans
that sort of
snake oil salesmen
that's
promised those efforts
to do more than they currently can
i think that her you know that goal that
she had that she created theranos to try
to achieve
to use less blood in tests is a very
worthy goal and a huge frontier that we
have not
achieved and that i hope we will achieve
so i understand why you know what
someone describes what a huge step
forward that would be and it would be
indeed i understand why people put a ton
of money behind it can you describe what
was the promise what what are we even
talking about what's their nose what
just uh for people who don't know so
theranose is a company that was
basically started to revolutionize the
way medical blood tests are done
both to use a whole lot less blood in
doing it you know if anyone's ever been
to the doctor and had five to ten tubes
of blood removed from them it can be uh
quite surprising how much they take out
uh and and it's
you know that's the limitation of our
technology that we need those volumes of
blood to run all the tests that we want
to and so the promise of theranos was
that perhaps with a single drop of blood
we would be able to know as much about
the person's the condition of their
their body um without drawing all that
blood and and thereby you know there
would be these devices she was going to
create that would sort of do it you put
a drop of blood in it spits out
everything you ever wanted to know about
what's in your bloodstream and in a way
that would make it so much easier you
know it could be you could have one in
your home theoretically and you i don't
know why you'd wonder what your
potassium level is on any given day but
you could check if you wanted to um and
so that that goal is very worthy you
know i i put that goal up there with
uh the the frontier of making
painkillers that are as good as opioids
without the addictive quality you know
that would be such a huge revolution if
we did have that in medicine but
and particularly for me because i
trained in both pediatrics and internal
medicine so i learned to care for both
children and adults in children we do
draw much less blood they have a much
lower blood volume and we use these tiny
little tubes to draw their blood
and we seemingly get
equivalent information out of the larger
tubes we draw from adults and i'm still
unclear to be honest why we can't draw
that little amount of blood from adults
it seems technically possible i don't
know what the barriers are i'm sure
there are or else we'd be doing it
but i do think that that is a very
important goal and if theranos had done
it they would have really revolutionized
the practice of medicine
so to
return to that
cadaver that first day
uh when you got to meet with the with
the dead with a
human body that's no longer living so
how
how quickly
did it take for you to get used to sort
of uh he said looking at the surface
muscles of the back
i mean
that can be overwhelming as a thought
and people listening to this that have
never dissected anything might might be
overwhelmed by that thought so like how
quickly were you able to get used to
the brutal honesty of the biology before
you
for me it did not take long at all i
guess i've not never been a squeamish
person so for me it was kind of riveting
and fascinating right from the first
moment but i do know some of my fellow
classmates did have some trouble with it
some of them i
heard had nightmares in the first few
weeks of anatomy lab
and but then everyone as far as i know
got used to it and that was also
actually a big lesson for me that it's
pretty amazing what people can get used
to in their daily lives and i kind of
extrapolated that to people living
through war and through you know just
terrible uh situations and
living under um you know oppressive
regimes and it it really is amazing what
people can get used to almost anything
but you know in war
people
often come back and they have nightmares
they suffer through it there's ptsd
there's uh there's a lot of complicated
feelings with that
are echoes of those same complicated
feelings possible
in the case of training to be and
becoming a doctor
that's a good point yeah i think you
know sometimes just as you know a barbed
wire fence can leave a scar on your skin
you know emotional uh psychological
experiences can leave a mark on your
brain or your memory and i think that
that definitely could be um
could be a problem in medical training
you do see a lot of things that are
very shocking very repulsive things that
you'd never forget i know one of those
students that had nightmares initially
went on to be a surgeon so i imagine
she's not having the ptsd of kind of
seeing inside her first dead body
because she sees inside them all day
every day now
but i'm sure it it could you know we we
go on to see so many um kind of
grosser or more shocking
things in medical training through
medical school and then by working with
actual living patients not just dead and
embalmed bodies
so i do think that things can leave a
mark but i don't think that initial
cadaver would be the most traumatic
yeah but maybe some of that trauma the
demons make you a better surgeon just
like
some of your own psychological trauma
might make you a better psychiatrist
returning to the ordering
is that order is a chaos to the ordering
of the chapters from throat and heart
and feces and genitals all the way to
fingers and toes and blood
so i i did mention that you know throat
was the first one because i kind of
wanted to throw the reader right into
the the brutal honesty of death
and i followed it up with feces as the
third chapter and in a way partly to
also throw them right into the deep end
of
how i like discussing parts of the body
and revealing their gross and
fascinating aspects so i didn't want to
hide anything you know when you train to
be a doctor everything is on the table
literally in the cadaver lab but also
just
you know you deal with blood and piss
and vomit and feces and that's kind of
the medium of your craft and
yes medium or the craft that's right
right like if you're a painter
this is the paint
exactly and then you have to create a
masterpiece with it
uh like almost like a dance because
there's multiple painters one of the
painters is the biology so let's return
to throat you mentioned it's a weird one
so first of all
a friend of mine said i i just see
humans
as a
like a bunch of holes that just walk a
walk around
it's
not
untrue it's a funny way to look at
humans so we have ears we have nose
uh we have mouth
we have
um the sexual holes vagina penis
and then uh
you know what's the uh medical term for
your [ __ ]
yes anus thank you
uh this is this is a very technical
discussion the rectum's further in don't
confuse the two oh that's very important
what what
is there a difference between throat and
mouth by the way so when you say throat
are we talking about
when that hole actually became becomes
tubular
so the throat i would count as just sort
of the very back of the of the you know
the back of the mouth where the nose
also comes down and meets it where the
tonsils are and the uvula
but you're right that you know we are a
bunch of holes but more accurately we're
a tube right we start in the womb as
kind of this microscopic little disc
almost like
a uh
you know a flat bread and then we're we
roll in almost like a burrito into this
tube and we're a simple microscopic tube
and from there we grow into this bigger
and bigger tube and we become more
complicated and each end of the tube
does split into various holes so all the
holes you mentioned at the front end of
the tube the front end of her body right
it splits into the nose
the mouth the ears the sinuses the the
tube to the
lungs which is the windpipe the tube
down to the stomach which is the
esophagus
and then the other end of the tube
splits as well uh you know men end up
with two holes
and women end up with three holes
um you know the urethra the vagina and
the anus and men just you know the
urethra and kind of the reproductive
system they share a hole so i'm learning
a lot today
it really is incredible that you start
from sperm and egg and you have some dna
information and from that the building
project begins
and then what that leads to is like a
like a like pizza dough and then you
roll it
into a tube and that tube then
eventually
sort of becomes more and more
complicated and gets
eyes and a brain
and then uh can create a twitter account
so for so from
it's it's really incredible that we're
just a fancy tube
right we are and we sprout eyes and a
brain and a sense of smell and taste
pretty much to regulate what comes in
the front of the tube you know we don't
want to eat anything dangerous or
poisonous you know we want to choose
what we eat
even choose who we kiss well we seem to
be motivated by what comes out of the
tube as well
in part
that's not just output it's a feedback
mechanism seemingly like we're also
monitoring the functioning of the output
we're not just obsessed about the input
we're very obsessed with the output
you're absolutely right about that
people you know have medical complaints
about their output very often that are
you know i'm never i never cease to be
surprised by a new kind of complaint or
observation about the output i think
people have gone to wars over
the output and uh maybe sometimes the
lack of the output or the desire for
output for the particular other humans
that you fancy the brain and the eyes
that sprouted somehow convinced
the
the rest of the body that this one
particular other tube is fanciful so
you're going to go to major wars and
lead global suffering because because of
the fancy and the desire for additional
output with the other
uh tube okay
so that's
so
uh on the throat
that part of the tube
is it uh
you said the design is not
you could have thought of maybe a little
bit better options because it's too
multi-functional is that
can you sort of elaborate on the
multifunctional nature of this part are
a lot of parts of the human body
multifunctional or do you find that more
specialization
is going to get the job done better
there is a lot of organs for instance do
have multiple functions you know the
pancreas has two it's like two organs in
one one you know secretes hormones like
insulin into the bloodstream and the
other aspect of it secretes uh digestive
enzymes into the gut to help you digest
and absorb food the liver is like 15
organs in one it's just amazing how many
different things it does
but the throat you know so basically the
problem with the throat is as i said
we have two tubes that are right next to
each other in the throat one is for food
drink saliva mucus snot whatever you're
gonna swallow
all of that stuff must go down the
esophagus the food tube and end up in
the stomach and right next to the
esophagus millimeters away
is the windpipe or the trachea which
goes down to the lungs
and your your throat does these daily
gymnastics to
keep everything but air
out of the windpipe because you know you
slip up once and you can die
uh you can choke you know you laugh or
speak while eating and its curtains
unfortunately so it seems like you know
every aspect of the body when i was
learning about it in med school seems so
brilliant and so perfectly designed by
evolution or whoever you might think
designed it um to you know favor
survival to enhance life
uh but the throat seemed the opposite it
seemed set up almost for failure
and uh you know we developed all these
mechanisms as a compensation right we
have the gag reflex whenever food or
something is headed towards your air
pipe your windpipe or down to your lungs
your throat has this sort of like
rejection of it it pushes it away in a
gag reflex
at the same time we have a cough which
is something our body does when
something inappropriate does get down
the windpipe you know when we get a
little food down the wrong pipe uh we
end up coughing and the coughing does
usually flush it out and get rid of it
we even have something called the mucus
elevator in our lungs which is this
constant flow of mucus up the airways up
to the trachea dragging with it all
kinds of particulates that we've inhaled
and perhaps some food that went down the
wrong pipe and drags it up into the
throat and we swallow it kind of
unconsciously all day every day is the
truth even the mechanism of swallowing
is super complicated you know uses a
number of cranial nerves it uses over 15
different muscles
um it's this coordinated act to keep
food out of the airway you know it you
can see someone's adam's apple and their
neck kind of jump upward when they
swallow
which helps lift the airway up against
this kind of the the epiglottis which
plugs it closed and allows food or
swallowed drink to kind of skirt just
past it but every time we swallow those
things do come within millimeters of
going down the wrong pipe and it's just
thanks to these kind of compensations
these adaptations we have to the danger
of the throat that keeps us alive
as i actually took a sip of uh water
it's it's kind of
it makes you appreciate
the wonderful machinery of it all
uh by the way we have uh pulled up your
instagram that people should follow you
have a post about the throat
and then just showing so many different
components from the tongue
to the trachea the esophagus
just the entire machinery of it all
the teeth for the chewing
it's so interesting and so a lot of the
structure of this the anatomy
and the physiology does it echo other
mammals
are we so are we just basically
borrowing a lot of stuff from evolution
and maybe
making small adjustments maybe due to
the fact that we're not using our mouth
to murder
things
as other predators might we use our
thumbs exactly we have hands we don't
need to bite them
um yeah there's a lot of overlap between
different animals which i find uh very
comforting and fascinating you know
someone asked me is there any animal in
which the throat is better designed and
i my first thought was whales because
the blowhole is kind of up on the top of
their head so i was thinking oh maybe
maybe they are set more separate but
when i looked into it actually no you
know the paths do come very close just
like in us and
i saw a paper about some new discovered
organ that actually helps keep food and
drink out of the airway in wales that
they hadn't ever noticed before so it's
a different mechanism but the same kind
of basic problem is that you know where
tubes and the air tube and food tube are
right next to each other how well do we
understand so just even lingerie on this
little part is there still some
mysteries about the complexity of the
system because you mentioned
just even for swallowing all these parts
in the brain that are responsible and
all all the different things that have
to like an orchestra play together do we
have a good sense from both a medical
perspective and a biology perspective or
is there still mysteries there's
definitely still mysteries we understand
a lot about for instance how the
swallowing mechanism you know is
coordinated it's
in the brain stem sometimes using some
higher levels of the brain
but it is a very thoughtless thing as
you mentioned when you drink the water
you know it's not something we have to
think about thankfully or we'd be
thinking about it all day
there's a lot we don't understand about
the basic mechanisms perhaps about how
the nerves fire and how they kind of you
know
coordinate on them on the microscopic
level how ions rush into and out of
nerve cells to kind of create that
electrical signal but
we sure understand a heck of a lot and
it's very fascinating
so moving on to
chapter two and we'll jump around uh he
actually said the liver um
does a lot of things i also saw you
retweet something
where
it said uh you know showing that the
liver is bigger than the heart
which is the body or the universe's way
of saying you should drink more and care
less it's a good line uh so you you give
props
uh like you said to the kidney to the
liver to the maybe
to the organs to the parts that don't
often
get as much credit as they deserve but
let us go for time to the human heart
we get chest pain
we talk about it when we talk about love
for some reason why do we talk about the
heart when we talk about love there
sometimes can actually be some chest
pain involved in love i remember when i
was a med student i was very smitten
with another medical student it was
totally brilliant and beautiful
and it actually does cause this kind of
burning in your chest i don't know what
that is i don't think it's from the
heart itself
i don't know if it was like acid reflux
because i was so nervous i'm not really
sure
but i definitely felt something in my
chest whenever i saw her i don't know
what that is but you could see why
someone might think oh you know maybe it
is your heart that's kind of the most
prominent organ in your chest when
people come to the er with chest pain
you know the big question is is it my
heart and that's my main job is figuring
out if it is or not
so i could see why um
you know the way ancients saw the
functions of different organs is
fascinating but often
hard to explain
would it be fair to say
that if you look at the entirety of
human history
the way most people die has to do with
the heart
well like in america today um
cardiovascular disease and and cardi you
know coronary artery disease is one of
the most common perhaps the most common
cause of death you know a 100 years ago
200 years ago it was probably not people
were not living as long and people were
dying of infections that we tend to die
less of these days
sure um that's true but in terms of
things to stab
so i'm trying to sort of introspect like
why
why talk about the heart and love
my thought would be that is because
the heart was seen as the most important
organism it would be like the origin of
life comes from the heart the originator
of life and the way you figure that out
from sort of an ancient perspective
is uh when you stab things
what is likely to lead to issues it's
like it's possible to imagine that the
brain is not as special as we might
think
from
when you don't understand modern biology
or um physiology or neuroscience all
those kinds of things especially because
pain
you know is painless too
uh if you stab it
the brain i mean yeah um
yeah anyway so that's that's really
interesting i'm sure there's a
there's a kind of a poetic answer to
maybe the way people wrote about it but
what to you is
the wisdom in the design of the heart i
mean the main function of the heart
basically is to push blood through the
cardiovascular system through the
branching
blood vessels to feed every cell in the
body you know when our i believe our
ancestors started off as single-celled
organisms floating in some ancient brew
and they were surrounded by the medium
that would bring them all the nutrients
they needed so there's no issues there
and then once you start getting
multicellular organisms the kind of that
are thicker and the ones on the inside
aren't in contact with that sort of
nutritious brew that they're growing in
you kind of need a way to distribute
those nutrients to every cell and so
that's what the heart and the branching
vascular tree do so the heart you know
it's i the most the biggest disconnect
between how the organs talked about in
poetry and through history versus his
actual function is probably the heart
because we ascribe all these things like
love and passion
and life itself sometimes to the heart
but actually it's just a simple
mechanical pump you know that's all it
is
i don't want to downplay it it's amazing
but um you know it just pushes it fills
the blood and then squeezes it fills the
bone squeezes it and just that squeezing
that pushing creates the blood pressure
that you need to get blood to every cell
in your body especially when you're
standing upright to get blood to your
brain you need a certain amount of
pressure to get it up there
isn't it
amazing to you how much volume of blood
just gets pushed through by this
by this pump
absolutely they say every red blood cell
takes about five minutes to circulate
and come back to the heart um and that
circulation kind of you know starts at
in the womb and continues and kind of
until the moment that we die
but the volume is tremendous and it can
never
see you know take a break basically and
it's sort of uh
propagating all kinds of stuff
throughout the body it's a delivery
mechanism blood for all kinds of good
stuff and bad stuff nutrition
drugs
all that right medications too
medications
such a fascinating design and it also
takes the waste away you know it kind of
brings the nutritious stuff brings the
nutrients especially oxygen but many
other things and then it also
as it passes the cell takes the cell's
waste so it's sort of the the fresh
water and the sewage system in one so
about blood
what what to use fascinating about blood
so we talk about the pump that spreads
the blood but the blood itself right so
the blood itself is sort of i mean it's
the most important bodily fluid of
course it you know from moment to moment
every cell in the body needs a flow of
blood
um to bring it most importantly oxygen
but also again all the other nutrients
and to take away waste and if that stops
for even a few moments you can be in big
trouble
so blood is sort of you know the the
most important medium it's also doctors
use it to kind of evaluate the body it
does have this kind of all-seeing
quality to it where um you know we can
evaluate organs through the blood i can
tell you about your liver your heart
your kidney just by taking a sample of
your blood
so it's sort of like this crystal ball
in a way and we use it kind of all the
time you know to assess someone's health
to assess their disease
is it also the attack vector for
diseases for bacteria for viruses and
all that kind of stuff so viruses seem
to attack either the throat maybe you
can correct me but they seem to attack
different parts of the body
depending on how easy it is to access
and how easy it is to uh
get in deep
depending on what you prefer if you want
to do a little bit of hard work
but you get in deep or you don't want to
do the hard work
but you don't get in deep those are the
choices viruses have but is blood one of
the sort of
attack factors what's like if you were
trying to break into the human body
uh
like a parasite a virus a bacteria
how would you do it like what would you
what would be the attack vectors you
would explore right so you got to look
for the body's weaknesses of course
um you know we have inherent weaknesses
for instance like our respiratory tract
we have to breathe we have to get air in
from the outside and so that's one of
the entries into the body and so you
know when we inhale let's say a
poisonous gas you know it's it's an easy
way in you have to breathe can't hold
your breath very long but you know air
in our lungs is still kind of contiguous
with the external atmosphere it's not
really inside the body until it does
cross across the lining of the alveoli
into the blood as you said that's when
it really gets inside and the other
besides the respiratory tract the
gastrointestinal tract is another way
kind of a [ __ ] in the armor you know we
have to eat we have to drink and
therefore we're taking the external
world into ourselves into our gut in
order to extract from it what we need
and let the rest kind of flow out
so those two the gastrointestinal and
respiratory tract you know there's a
reason that you know respiratory tract
infections
and gastrointestinal infections are kind
of the most common that afflict us
because those are the ways in to the
body so i would definitely pick one of
those
not just be a lazy cold in the nose but
really a more aggressive pneumonia down
deep in the lungs and get across that
barrier into the blood
but also
the whole sex thing
uh that humans do
so
speaking of which let us go for time
to the genitals chapter
so uh what are genitals i think i've
heard of those
i think i've read about a penis and a
vagina can you explain
to me how those work just asking for a
friend but also
um what do you use fascinating about it
and maybe what's
misunderstood or little known about them
sure so i'm they're very unique organs i
would say one of the things that i like
to point out is that you know while
every organ from moment to moment keeps
us alive and ensures our survival the
genitals are in a way the opposite you
know
we don't need them from moment to moment
you don't even have to use them at all
um and in fact they often make us do
stupid things that are the opposite of
kind of enhancing survival so
and they you know they've affected the
brain and you can become sort of focused
and nuts based on those desires that
kind of stem from the genitals so they
can be dangerous organs too um but you
know i mean sexual dimorphism helps with
genetic variability um as it does in so
many other organisms you know you take
two people and mix them together their
genetics you just get a lot more
variation and more opportunities to try
different genetic codes and see what'll
enhance survival as we talked about sex
and death
i talk about in the book a lot of for
instance the female genital tract how
the uterus is very unusual because you
know it doesn't even sort of wake up and
start doing its thing until the second
decade of life you know it's um even
though
uh babies uh baby female babies are born
with all of the eggs they'll ever have
in their ovaries already they're just
sort of in this stasis until they start
waking up uh kind of once a month
and it's this this cycle you know
there's so much in our bodies that are
cyclical and rhythmic the heartbeat the
breathing
but menstruation is kind of the a very
strange rhythm that takes over a decade
to start
and only you know the rhythm beats once
a month which is very slow compared to
every other rhythm of the body the other
unusual thing is you know in in medicine
when rhythms of the body cease when they
stop those are emergencies right when
your heart stops that's a cardiac arrest
you need cpr maybe an electric shock to
restart it when your breathing stops you
know you need a breathing machine to
breathe for you or something to reverse
whatever might be causing the
suppression of your breathing but when
the menstruation stops it's the point of
menstruation in the first place
the whole reason that the uterus grows
the lining and sheds it each month is to
one day you know
get
get fertilized fertilization for to
implant in the lining and then the
rhythm ceases and that's obviously not a
medical emergency unlike most other
rhythms you know cessations it's the
point of the whole thing in the first
place so these particular
penis and vagina are that whole thing
the uterus whatever am i not using the
wrong terms
i don't know i'll just keep saying you
use those terms there's more technical
there's parts various various parts in
medical school you learn
every bump and you know every little
part of every little organ and including
the genitals so
i never really uh thought of it this way
as you said
is that most organs are kind of
full-time employees
like uh 24 7 they're doing something and
then there's some organs uh
penis vagina being
uh representative of this they're not
functioning all the time they're only
functioning every once in a while and
then get us to do
stupid stuff or awesome stuff and all
that kind of stuff but they're not
essential for human survival on a second
by second basis
and that the whole cyclical nature of
the human body
how many other cycles are on a monthly
basis like
that far apart that's a that's a
fascinating design that the human body
would do that and wouldn't start
until the second decade a decade of life
it's almost like
what do i want to say there's some kind
of
meta planning going on
like this is the optimal solution for
the sexual selection mechanism
among
uh like somewhat intelligent species
like it's useful to
after the brain has developed
sufficiently long
to now be making sexual selection
decisions like you need time for this
computer this really powerful computer
to load in the info
interesting you also need the body to
develop you know a child simply isn't
big enough to get pregnant and deliver a
you know another baby i wonder if
there's animals in which this happens
much more accelerated pace in different
stages definitely especially you know
certain kinds of insects you know like
um drosophila a lot of the fruit fly a
lot of experiments are done on because
their life cycle is so rapid you know a
lot of kind of insects and other
creatures are almost ready to mate as
soon as they're born
not us
not us is there any
improvements to the design
so a lot of people are very interested
in these particular body parts
if you were to sort of step back as a
geneticist biological designer or maybe
a computer scientist computer engineer
trying to build
a
human 2.0 or maybe a robot how would you
improve
the penis and the vagina
well the penis for starters i mean let's
also discuss the testicles you know
they're very important too i mean okay
so they're yes right so they're fragile
and they're important and yet they're
hanging off the body in danger basically
so um does that make sense
you know they begin in the womb they
begin inside the abdomen and they slowly
descend and and sometimes before birth
sometimes in the first year of life
sometimes never they pop out of the body
and end up hanging in the scrotum
there's a reason because the chemical
reactions that create sperm
function best at a few degrees cooler
than body temperature and so that's why
you might notice in the warm weather
they might hang further down and in the
cold weather they scrunch themselves up
to get closer to the body to maintain
that ideal temperature a few degrees
cooler
so it's hard you know if you could
create a sperm production mechanism that
did not rely on that lower temperature
that would be great keep them inside the
body protected like the ovaries are
um oh then you wouldn't rely on the
lower temperature i thought you meant
create some kind of weird internal
cooling mechanism no well
no i guess that would be one solution
but just maybe a different type of
chemical reaction or you know would not
be reliant on the lower temperature
let's say um you know it would be great
to design the
spermatogenesis or sperm production
process that would function best at body
temperature and then we can keep those
delicate organs inside the body and not
have them hanging out in danger
or maybe the argument for this design is
uh
maybe
it's nice to put them in danger so you
uh are constantly concerned about it
could be maybe that's beneficial for
male psychology i'm not really sure
there's a psychological element here
about the evolution that could be so
that's the testicles uh
uh penis
um a better way to do it you know i i
mean it's pretty good as it is you know
it kind of when it's time for it to work
it it grows and stiffens and when it's
time for it not to work it it kind of
shrinks and yeah hangs out
um
saw this on a seinfeld episode so i know
how it works shrinkage yeah that was a
good one but you know that's that's also
a bit unique i suppose that uh you know
the way it's it has this erectile tissue
actually they're similar
in the mouth of certain baleen whales
there's a certain
similar kind of erectile tissue that
helps um cool cool them off
um because they have so much blubber
and creates so much heat and moving
around and feeding that they have
actually a similar similar to the penis
organ in their mouth that helps cool
their bodies because it's a big problem
they have to store all that blubber for
fuel but it makes them too hot so as a
compensation they have this kind of
erectile organ in their mouth okay
uh what about vagina you know the fact
that
miscarriages sometimes happen because of
sexually transmitted diseases because of
trauma you know it would be great if the
uterus where the growing fetus is is
sort of even more protected from those
things
um
you know i guess that's that's a side
effect of the fact that uh people still
have sex when they're pregnant are still
you know exposed to injury if there's a
way to make it more protected perhaps
that would be even better i did see an
article recently about artificial wombs
which are
rapidly becoming a reality and in in
animal studies they're able to prolong
the gestation of a fetus by a month in
an artificial womb
can you explain the artificial aspect of
the artificial one sure it's um
i believe it it acts almost like a a
heart lung bypass machine so when
someone's getting like bypass surgery
their heart is stopped literally they
throw ice in the chest and they um
give a potassium infusion through the
blood which stops the heart
um but the blood is run through a
machine
that basically does what the work of the
heart and lungs together gets oxygen
into the blood and then pushes it in
back into the body so it's i believe
it's a sort of similar mechanism to keep
blood and nutrition flowing to this
fetus
and so it's just not inside the body of
a parent it's in some kind of other
device but i think that science is going
to rapidly improve one benefit is you
know babies are born premature and while
you know
neonatology is able to continuously kind
of lower the age of viability through
better technology and understanding how
what you can medicines and other things
you can do to premature babies when
they're born you know ideally if let's
say premature labor begins you can't
stop it
that baby's coming out one way or the
other if you could just then stick it
into an artificial womb where it can
continue its development that would save
a whole host of problems often those
babies born very early suffer from
damage to various organs including the
brain you know for the rest of their
life so that could be a very important
technology
so some aspects of the human body
we can develop technologies that
outsource them sort of uh
offload some of the stress
and the workload from the human body to
do it elsewhere like dialysis does that
for kidneys you know people can live
decades without kidneys as long as they
get
dialysis which does the work for them
not every organ can do that for instance
the liver there's no dialysis version
for the liver like if your liver fails
you need a liver transplant and that's
the only thing that's gonna do it for
you
so that's the world's first artificial
womb
for humans and we're looking at a
picture
of what looks like gigantic balloons
matrix here we come
this is very matrixy how are they
floating
what are we even looking at
there's giants
red spheres this really looks like the
matrix
i wonder where it's from so there seems
to be a paper on this too
i don't know too much about it but i did
see that there it's advancing very
rapidly the world's first artificial
wound for humans scientists in the
netherlands say they're within 10 years
of developing an artificial womb that
could save the lives of premature babies
premature birth before 37 weeks is
globally the biggest cause of death
among newborns but the development also
raises ethical questions about the
future of baby making
and so on and so forth wow we're going
to be facing a lot of ethical questions
as we start to mess
with human biology
in in in an effort to help
human biology we might start to mess
with it
and it's going to be very interesting
let's take steps towards um
towards the matrix
all right
what about the neighbors poop
feces
there seems to be
a lot of interesting stories
in that particular output as well
um
what what to you is
fascinating
what um
what to you maybe is misunderstood
or a little known about
poop
well it's hilarious for one thing yeah
that we do
okay the word is great as well yes
there's so many different words i do you
know when i'm talking to the parents of
pediatric patients i use the word poop i
don't often when i'm talking to adult
patients try to choose a more mature
word but um
poop is amazing i mean i guess it's uh
you know it's sort of the most the
dirtiest the most vile the most hated
aspect of our bodies it's the grossest
we don't want to think about it talk
about it have an it anywhere near our
you know food or in social interactions
uh with good reason you know i mentioned
gastrointestinal infections are one of
the most common infections the human
body suffers from and
you know what we call uh the way they
spread from person to person grossly
enough is referred to as the fecal oral
route which is means a bit of someone's
stool is getting into your you're
swallowing it um you know through water
supply
for instance diarrhea is actually quite
a brilliant mechanism of these microbes
right if you let's say you're in the
intestine of one person your goal is to
get into the intestines of another
person
brilliant to just trick their intestines
into secreting all this fluid into into
the intestines to increase the volume of
stool and its runniness so that when
they do poop it gets into the water
supply and then everyone else kind of
ends up getting infected as well wow
it's genius just the same way like you
know tuberculosis or coronavirus kind of
infects your lungs and makes you cough
and you send it out into the air and it
ends up in other people's lungs that's
all evolution yeah it's brilliant so
diarrhea is intelligent um is a big
takeaway lesson
it's one of the most intelligent things
we can do uh as an entirety of an
organism not just the particular
cognitive organism but there's
there's you know we're we're made up of
bacteria and viruses and there's a lot
of visitors and so on as the entirety of
the system diarrhea is one of our better
accomplishments that's fascinating
um well i wonder
why is poop funny
i think a lot of that is socially
constructed just how it's sort of
supposed to be hidden away yet something
we always do something you know we
chuckle about as children and
but even in healthcare you know it
becomes this big topic of conversation
because you end up talking about it
constantly like in the er people come in
i there's complete strangers sometimes
like a nice old lady who resembles my
grandmother and all of a sudden i have
to ask her all about what's happening in
the bathroom like is she straining what
color is it what what you know what's
the consistency
does it float on top of the water more
than it should is it hard to flush i
mean there's a million different
questions you learn
as a as a medical student and you're
like this poop detective when people
come in with issues
and so it's
it's funny i guess you know in the exam
room with the doctor-patient
relationship there's sort of no barriers
you know you talk about everything and
you're talking about the most intimate
details of a person's life even though
you just met them a second ago it's so
different than normal social
interactions yet there is this social
aspect a lot of what i do is social you
know it seems like doctors what they do
is mostly scientific but actually it's
just relating to another person and you
have to
maintain you know your professional
demeanor and this normal human level
interaction even though you're talking
about poop
um
and that's a skill that's an art and a
science well okay actually i want to
linger on that because i'm a fan of just
diving into conversations right away
with strangers
just getting no small talk
and this is like the ultimate
i don't know if it's the ultimate but
it's one version of no small talk you
get right to the point
i um that's really powerful from a
psychology perspective you're a kind of
therapist or you have the power
to be a therapist i don't mean just
about the medical condition of the body
but the psychological there's so much
fear connected uh to to this
concern
also
self-doubt
um insecurities
even uh sort of existential thoughts
about your mortality all those things
are right there in the room
um so i think one way doctors deal with
that is they kind of have this cold way
about them they almost have to do a mode
one is like i'm going to be
friendly on the surface
and cold about the
brutal honesty of the biology
but i wonder if there's like um
a skillful middle ground
this dangerous place where
you can help people deal with their
psychological insecurities concerns
fears all those kinds of things is that
just really tough to do
yeah it's it's a huge part of being a
doctor is is dealing with the
psychological aspects of whatever is
going on with the patient's body i mean
in the er you deal with psychiatric
emergencies kind of left and right more
than ever these days and um you know
that's a huge issue not to mention sort
of drug use alcohol-related stuff you
know that gets into sort of psychology
and the human love of intoxicants and
changing the brain's chemistry
um and you know inhabit of course we're
creatures of habit and that plays in as
well i mean a big part of for instance
pediatrics is reassuring parents and
kind of convincing them
giving them the confidence that what's
going on with their child is not serious
will go away on its own does not need
any particular intervention
and but adults too you know reassurance
is a huge part
of the game
um
yeah you know in the er you see humanity
at its most raw i feel like you get this
tremendous insight into people how they
live what they worry about what they
think about how their body works and
also how their mind works that
you almost don't see anywhere else it's
a really interesting um place to work
and also the way our society is shaped
the er is where people go for almost
everything when they're suicidal they
come to the er when they're too high on
drugs to walk they come to the er you
know children who have been abused
sexually abused physically abused come
to the er for us to investigate uh it's
sort of like the the all-purpose waste
bin for the dregs of society what people
do to themselves and what they do to
other people
you know you mentioned you're interested
in the darkness of humanity it made me
think of the er where you really see
uh what human life is like um in the er
okay you've uh you tweet about you write
about you think about the emergency room
er
that's really fascinating
just a little window you uh give to that
world it's fascinating
what
lessons about humanity do you draw
from this
place where you're so near to death
there's so much chaos
there's so much variety of what's wrong
so little information
um or the
the the urgent nature of the
information inflows such that you can't
really reason
sort of thoroughly and deeply and
collect all the data all those kinds of
things you have to act fast and then
everybody's freaking out can you just
speak to the human condition
[Music]
that you get a glimpse at
through the er experience
yeah i think you do see all those things
i think on on one end
of the spectrum it is this very unique
place where you get all these unique
insights on the other end it can become
a ho-hum workplace just like any other
which is sort of surprising as i
mentioned before humans seem to be able
to get used to almost anything
and doctors can get ho-hum used to oh
dying of a heart attack oh actively in
labor and the baby's half out oh you
know just
ho-hum i know what to do going about my
job and go home at have dinner with my
family and not think too much about it
that's amazing
i do i do try to maintain you know both
my fascination you know as i think
writers in general tend to think more
about what they see write more about
what they see maybe draw connections
with what they see to other things so i
do think that writer's perspective does
help me
uh kind of maintain my fascination and
my kind of more of an insightful
perspective than just a ho-hum water
cooler conversation um
but you do see a lot you know um
in a way medical problems are sort of
the great equalizer right um class
race culture background you know the
failings of the human body the way it
fails and what we can do to help in
those situations is almost universal i
always like this quote from you know
chekhov was a doctor and a writer and he
uh saw treated a lot of peasants very
low class and also treated a lot of
aristocrats and he he wrote that they
all have the same ugly bodies basically
which i think is really uh right on and
you know it's sort of you can see people
underneath a superficial layer of
clothing maybe it's the most expensive
clothing bought from the fanciest places
but underneath their body is still
failing in the same way and they still
have the same anxieties the same worry
about mortality the same concerns about
whether poop turned green today
all these things that they bring to the
table so in a way it is this great
equalizer um where people are kind of
all the same in some ways
yeah i feel like people sometimes
class money
fame
power
makes you for time forget that you're
just
a meat vehicle
and uh and
just as good and just as bad as the
other meat vehicles
all around you
in that sense
uh
there's this question sometimes raised
are some people better than others
and i usually answer no to that question
because of that
yeah some people might be better at math
some people might be better at music
but at the end we're just meat bags
beautiful as we are there's a poem that
just uh a small tangent i want to take i
just
saw it just acting
that you have
uh written i have to uh would you
classify it as a poem yeah
at first if i may read it at first you
enter the clinic shoulders weighed down
by white coat pockets book stuffed
timid
you act out a roll
your white coat a costume your questions
a script
your demeanor a rehearsed act
no one is going to buy this
but then
as you play the role again and again
repeating the lines and the motions the
script slowly dissolves and the
interaction becomes thoughtless
and the rehearsed act slowly fades into
a profession
you suddenly find yourself unable to
tell if you're still acting or
if you're doing it for real and now
you're a doctor
jonathan reisman md harvard
massachusetts general hospital medicine
and pediatrics department beautiful so
that is
what it is to be a doctor you're just
acting fake it till you make it exactly
fake it till you make it and i think i
imagine every medical student has this
feeling when they first go into a room
like i talked about
asking this nice old lady about the
color of her poop for the first time and
you're just like what am i doing here
like what did does she believe i'm a
doctor you know this just feels absurd
but then it's again ho-hum becomes
normal
now there's not a sperm chapter in your
book
this uh you mentioned offline that this
is the second and the third book that
you're working on all about sperm no i'm
just kidding um
but or maybe i'm not
uh humor tends to make way for reality
um
so the the tweet was that a human
average human male produces 500 billion
sperm i believe which is about four to
five times more
than
the number of people who have ever lived
and each of those sperm is genetically
unique so you can think of them you can
kind of imagine the possible humans they
could have created and they're all
different
they have similarities of course but
they have peculiarities that make them
different and you can think of all the
different trajectories all the einsteins
the feynmans the hitlers
and all the people who have died who
would have died during
childbirth
would have died early in their years
given the different diseases it's
fascinating to think about
an average human
yeah we're all winners of a very
competitive race so the people who make
it
we're winners hashtag winning um is
there something
that
you find
fascinating
interesting beautiful
ugly
surprising about sperm
i think sperm is um yes it is a very
interesting bodily fluid maybe i'll
write about it in a second or third book
we'll see but uh
you know i guess sperm is interesting
because it's kind of the only
projectile bodily fluid um from the body
um you know
vomit can be projectile usually that's a
disease state that's not the expected
kind of normal healthy state oh sneezing
would you classify that or no true i
guess there's it's yeah there's some
particles in the air i guess it's not a
fluid i mean not a liquid um
but true i mean cough in addition to
sneeze right sneeze is how our nose gets
rid of something that shouldn't be there
cough is our lungs get rid of something
that shouldn't be there vomiting is
sometimes our stomachs get rid of
something that shouldn't be there
all projectile sometimes in their own
way
sperm is sort of interesting it's
created with the food for its journey
sperm mostly feed off of fructose the
kind of sugar um you know for the few
days that they live inside the female
genital tract but it's sort of i like
comparing our genitals to the genitals
of the plant world which is flowers and
in the same way that uh
you know a touch me not uh for instance
the kind of flower where when you brush
up against it it sort of launches seeds
into the distance to try to um
survive in a way kind of the sperm is
doing something similar launched into
the female genital tract and then all
trying to find this uh competing against
each other to find this egg it's really
amazing and when you learn about it from
the biological perspective
the most amazing thing is how many
things can go wrong
you know just in the sperm not surviving
long enough for it making it to the egg
and then some genetic
abnormality causing a miscarriage it's
sort of astounding
that it works as often as it does and i
think the lesson there is just that
people have a lot of sex and so
statistics just favorite's going to work
out a good number of times
yeah and there might be intelligence in
the design of just the sheer number of
sperm maybe that's yet another way to
inject variety into the system
and redundancy i guess you know we have
two kidneys we have two hands if we lose
one we can still go on we have
you know however many millions of sperm
get sort of launched in every
ejaculation is uh you know if a bunch
fail
or don't make it inside there's papers
on this by the way uh that i read for
some reason not read but skimmed
for some reason which is uh talking
about which sperm usually wins like what
are the characteristics of sperms that
are winning and it's not the fastest
it says
apparently there's some kind of
slaughter that happens early on people
will correct me but it's not the fastest
it's there's a aspect of it's the
luckiest it really is like the body
tries to make it a random selection
it tries to make it fair in making it as
random as possible
interesting and also interesting that
they're fueled by fructose i didn't
really think about that so they're a um
they're a
car bloated athlete
right with food for the journey food for
the journey because i'm somebody that
actually does a lot of running
on um
i guess you would call me a fat adapted
athlete so i do sort of meat
heavy diet and so you could do a lot of
endurance kind of stuff
when you don't eat any carbs any glucose
any of that kind of stuff
and you're very low it's interesting to
think that sperm are like nope
they're total bros let's go to the gym
sprint
performance short term performance is
everything
all right well
that's sperm returning to the liver the
place
that deals with all our poor decisions
no um many of them many of the are poor
decisions is there um
you said that deliver does
uh quite a few things uh what do you use
fascinating beautiful about the liver i
would say its primary function seems to
be as the sort of gatekeeper for what we
eat and absorb
um you know the entire gastrointestinal
tract from the esophagus to the rectum
the blood flows from it not back to the
heart but to the liver where it's first
examined kind of things are evaluated
packaged
you know processed detoxified perhaps
and it's kind of this great overseer of
what we digest and absorb
and so it kind of keeps
keeps track of of what's coming in you
know the outside world that comes in and
become will become part of us you know
why that's why partly the liver suffers
sometimes the injury from
uh certain certain toxins like alcohol
but beyond that the liver is also the
place as i said it metabolizes things
too so it metabolizes alcohol and why it
can be injured by alcohol it metabolizes
drugs like tylenol which is why
tylenols uh can be very toxic to the
liver when taken out as an overdose
so the liver you know even beyond that
the liver produces a lot of different
you know things that float in the
bloodstream it packages cholesterol and
fats and sends them to where they're
needed it deals with protein in the
blood it deals with clotting factors in
the blood helping the blood clot um you
know
processes things like bilirubin and
other things that really as i mentioned
there's like 15 organs wrapped into one
maybe that's why it's sort of the
biggest internal organ the skin's bigger
but it's not an internal organ
right the biggest
organ in the human body is the skin
right
but the liver is the biggest internal
organ and it really is a powerhouse and
and does a lot which is why when people
suffer from liver failure kind of
everything goes wrong in a way
and uh in terms of replacing organs
what
what are organs that are easily
replaceable which are not
like on the list of things that are hard
to replace and not
where would you put a number one
where would you put it like at the
bottom well i'd say the kidneys are you
know nothing's easy but kidneys are
easiest in a way
partly i mean maybe a big factor there
is that other people have two of them
and can give one to you so you don't
have to wait for people to die which is
the case with hearts and livers
sometimes you can take a part of a liver
from someone who's alive and the liver
does have this kind of
mythological ability to regenerate
itself um in the myth of promise
prometheus he's you know chained to a
rock and the bird eats his liver every
day and it grows back every day
and that's uh actually biologically
accurate not that you can completely get
rid of it and it'll appear again but
when pieces of it are removed or injured
it does regenerate itself pretty
amazingly um
so i'd say the kidneys the fact that
they're more around also it's you know
the kidneys a smaller organ it's often
just you don't have to put a
transplanted kidney where the kidney
should be in the back of the abdomen you
can just kind of stuff it into the
pelvis there because it's a smaller
organ the liver would be hard because
it's huge
and i guess we just have the most
experience with kidney transplants
because they are the most common
and then the heart and the brain are
probably
quite difficult brain as far as i know
hasn't been successfully done the heart
is is done um
and uh
definitely i've evaluated a lot of
patients with a heart transplant it does
work pretty well the mechanical heart
substitutes are also advancing quite
rapidly these days for a failing heart
there's certain kinds of devices they
can surgically implant like when a
failing heart isn't able to push hard
enough you know that's the heart's job
is pushing blood with sufficient
pressure to create blood pressure
when it fails there are actually these
devices you can strap onto the heart to
help it pump harder those are rapidly
advancing many of those were not
available even 10 years ago when i was a
got out of med school and now they're
commonly used so maybe heart transplant
won't be as necessary in the future if
those mechanical things do advance and
as i said the heart is basically a
mechanical pump so perhaps it would be
the easiest organ to replace with some
mechanical device now for something
completely different returning to
testicles for time you posted uh
instagram posts
of uh testicles as food
perhaps eating them doesn't help libido
because
ingested testosterone is totally
metabolized in the liver returning to
our liver
leaving none to reach the bloodstream
that is why testosterone only comes as
injection or
topical foam not as pills on the other
hand estrogen and progesterone can be
absorbed orally hence the pill but
testosterone is mostly responsible for
libido in women too i was not expecting
for this biology lesson when i was
looking at an instagram picture
of
are we looking at testicles yeah are
these
like
which species i believe all those are
from cows from cows sexually female so
bulls yeah well uh speaking of which
just we'll jump around a bit but you've
also traveled the world
quite a bit
uh
what have you
what is the craziest food you've eaten
across the world what what have you
learned about the extremes
of the culinary arts
by traveling the world
i would say i guess i've always been
extra fascinated with the diets of of
natives of the far north um i spent some
time there in russia and in alaska
and
always loved
their diet so when i was i worked in
alaska an emergency room and did some
other travels in the antarctic alaska
and
you know they eat a lot of fat and
traditionally before contact you know
more than half of all calories in the
inupiat eskimo diet came from
blubber marine mammal fat or you know
also fat from fish fat from ducks and
other other birds that go up there to
mate in the summer
so things like raw whale blubber
um was especially uh interesting for me
and very exciting you know i had some uh
beluga beluga whale chowder things like
that there's just all these
very unusual dishes
uh you know they uh there's a dish
called mickey yuck which is
whale uh meat fermented in whale blood
which is quite delicious actually so is
it uh cooked does it eat in raw is it
what how do they like their fat like in
in uh
and then same in up north in russia as
you mentioned so they often eat it raw
so the raw whale blubber is called
muktuk um and it's often just sliced
thin and it's like it's sort of cold but
not frozen often when they eat it and
they slice it thin and
a lot of people assume it would be very
chewy but it's not that chewy it's quite
pleasant actually and has this kind of
sea smell to it as you're eating it i
quite like it
and what's the culinary culture like
meaning
is it just source of energy or is it art
well there's you know traditionally
there's not a lot of cooking um in you
know in the in the arctic uh a lot of
things are eaten raw partly because
there's not a lot of fuel for making
fires so um they will you know some in
some of the big rivers in russia for
instance that flow north they will bring
trees you know dead trees and logs up to
the north and they can get some wood
that way and same thing and some of the
rivers kind of flowing northward from
the brooks range of alaska
you do get some trees but just not
enough to really
produce a
culinary art that requires
cooking with heat you know they do have
um
traditionally blubber lamps where the
blubbers of seals and whales are used to
create a little flame
often that's for light and for a little
bit of heat
and and less for cooking
but eating things raw is definitely a
huge part of the culture there and while
i was i went on a whale hunting trip out
on the spring ice um in the arctic ocean
by barrow alaska
and uh two of the guys the inupiat guys
who had invited me were kind of talking
about how eating things raw is sort of
the most essential characteristic of an
opiate culture and the one guy who's
half white half an opiate said people
often doubt his ethnicity because he
looks like a white guy so he'll you know
bite the head off of a raw bird uh to
show them that he's truly a nupia is
what he said
that's how you prove you're legit we're
looking at instagram pic
as a doctor i was used to knowing fat as
the most maligned of all body parts and
the culprit in an obesity epidemic but
in arctic alaska fat has always meant
health and survival in fact the entire
story of life in the arctic especially
human life is basically a tale of fat
and in borough
what's a.k.a alaska alaska okay uh uh a
lawn covered with the whale blubber is
still equivalent of a plush green lawn
in temperature suburbia swelling in uh
its owner with pride and that's what
we're looking at is a lawn full of will
uh blubber
a beautiful this so this is i mean
there's a lot of calories there oh yeah
and this can feed a lot of people a lot
of energy a lot of warmth
absolutely and it's delicious this was
like uh
i was a kid in a candy store basically i
rounded a corner and barrow so when
people do get a whale during the spring
uh whaling season they raise a flag or
the whaling captain raises a flag over
his house and everyone in town is
welcome to come try some and so
before i went inside to try some i was
kind of playing around with blubber and
i saw the this is a bow head whale um i
saw its heart
which was huge like the size of a yoga
ball um and that was for me just like
amazing i spent probably the next 45
minutes just looking at all aspects of
it and the stump of aorta that was
attached to it was the size of my thigh
that was really fascinating
it's similar alaska and northern russia
like siberian out there so where were
you um
i think you have some picks
from that time where were you in russia
so i spent a lot of time in kind of
western russia as well but i did um take
two trips to kamchatka including
northern kamchatka um i didn't go far
enough nor i didn't go to chukotka for
instance until more recently when i was
a ship doctor on a wildlife cruise
that sailed from anadir russia up to
through the bering strait and to wrangel
island
and we stopped in some villages in
jukotka and i got a chance to to try
some some whale and stuff like that
northern kamchatka where it's more of
the koryak are the indigenous people
they do a lot of seal hunting so i had a
lot of seal blubber but they i don't
believe they do any whale hunting um
quite there but the chukchi in a way are
sort of you know similar to the nupia um
in their diet and their life ways of
course everyone's diet all these
people's diet has changed dramatically
in the last 100 years as it has for
actually everyone living in kind of
modern societies
but for them perhaps more than anyone
else since their diet was the most
extreme i think of any human culture on
earth
just to stay on
the wild travel you did and i should say
i'm using the word travel but it really
you were a doctor there
first of all can you just comment on the
decision to go to
such places
and to help people to be adopted there
what was the motivation what was the
thinking behind it well i think i got
the travel bug before i ever went to
medical school and even wanted to be a
doctor so right after college i kind of
wasn't very into college didn't enjoy
things kind of wanted to get out there
and see the world
get out of new york city where i was a
student at nyu um
the first thing i did after finishing
college was i was invited to be a intern
at a research center in saint petersburg
russia i spent six months there my first
trip and
went back four more times
to russia traveled all over including to
kamchatka twice um and other
parts of the country i'd never heard of
cities like petros of voldsk and
sikdivkar and scoff i didn't even know a
word could start with psk like the city
of scoff but it can yeah
and i was sort of fascinated i was
actually studying
uh the international environmental
movement and how it came to russia after
the fall of the soviet union and how
organizations like greenpeace and world
wildlife fund
and the world bank are trying to kind of
uh push the timber industry which is
huge in russia toward a more sustainable
path and so sort of evaluating how is it
working if not why not and that seems
like such a little niche such a small
detail about russian society but in a
way researching that in depth was almost
this window into the entire country and
the history in a place i knew nothing
about and i learned the language
traveled all over the country
you know got to know the food the
history the literature is just a
immersive and amazing and life-changing
experience that made me want to see
every
every spot on the globe basically learn
about every culture
so i took that desire with me to medical
school
i decided i would go to medical school
and uh from the very beginning i was
intent on traveling around the world
so a lot of my career has been fashioned
so that i'm practicing medicine in a
place with an interesting geographic
context an interesting place with an
interesting cultural context
and that just makes it more interesting
i find not only are medical services
often more needed in these remote and
rural parts of the country and world so
i feel like i'm you know taking my
knowledge and education experience to
places where it's needed but also for me
it's just such an enlightening
experience
the way culture history geography
climate affects medical disease but just
getting to know people getting to know
their culture
being a very useful traveler by you know
providing medical services in that place
and that's taken me to arctic alaska
to pine ridge reservation south dakota i
currently work in a few different parts
of pennsylvania appalachia which you
know for me is a unique geography and
culture that i didn't grow up with
wasn't familiar with so
in some ways it's it's exotic for me as
well i mean i worked in other places too
like calcutta
india and nepal um just i think my love
of travel has shaped my medical career
and and being a doctor does give you
these opportunities to go to places and
travel in a unique way you know through
the medical profession
you know there's a documentary happy
people here in the taiga or something
like that um
i think uh warner herzog voices it
it tells a story of a simple life of
survival
in the taiga and i think they're
trapping for food
and
there's a lot there's an alcoholism
problem too as well there's like a very
basic
life of survival of loneliness of
desperation but also there's a
i think the underlying claim
of the documentary is that
um that simple life
actually has a kind of
simple happiness to it
um hence the name happy people is there
can you speak to the life that people
live in
in those places when it may be simpler
than you would in uh sort of
big city life
it's definitely very different for sure
um you know i guess
i found like in some of the remote
villages of kamchatka
i was actually surprised how similar
they were in that you know there was i
saw the same family strife
the same fights the same
you know kind of pairing of
relationships and
bickering and politics and you know in a
way
i'm from the new jersey suburbs and yet
being in this remote you know uh village
of north northern kamchatka i remember
writing an email to my friend about how
just it seemed so similar even though on
the surface it was this exotic other
world
the incredible material know-how they
must have to get their food from the
land you know that
the number of animal species plant
species the behaviors of the animals
seasons um
how to live that way in a way it's more
complicated in a way that i find
fascinating how people live on the land
and the knowledge and experience it
takes to do it well and survive
you know obviously other aspects of
modern life in a city are are much more
complicated um
than they would be there but i guess
it's that was something that struck me
too that it's simpler in some ways but
more complicated in other ways so some
of the complexity that happens in life
is from originated from humans not from
the technology or the all that kind of
stuff around us
you can take the human out of modernity
but they're still human they're still
human and they fill the empty space with
their own human complexities um are
there people that
just stand out
memorable people memorable experiences
from those places
some people that maybe
made you smile made you cry
um change who you are as a man change
who you are as a doctor
anything jumps to mind i think you know
when i was is interesting when i was in
russia i found that
most of the people i hung out with were
old women i'm not sure why i mean
they're actually i didn't meet a lot of
old men in russia which might speak to
kind of
life expectancy there for men in
particular
but
i found uh women older russian women
including you know russian from saint
petersburg or some of the elderly women
in kamchatka who were you know some were
koryak some were half koryak half
russian some were chukchi
i just found them to have to be so
enlightening the way they talked about
history about people so insightful about
humanity you know all they've lived
through in the last 50 years in some of
these parts of russia
like the upheaval societal upheaval the
destruction the building up it's just
something i could not even imagine
and i think their insights were just
very i'm not thinking of anything in
particular but i just remember i could
listen to some of these elderly women
talk about their lives for hours and
hours i remember there was this older
elderly blind koreak woman
who you would have thought was the you
know most country bumpkin of country
bumpkin and yet she couldn't stop
talking about how much she loved reading
dostoevsky and tolstoy and which might
also speak to the soviet education
system
and it's just sort of surprising and
fascinating and just uh those stories
and perspectives on life really stayed
with me
yeah with uh
uh
there's a there's a wisdom there's a
kindness
i mean i suppose that's true for
older people in general but there's
something about
it's not just russia it's eastern europe
it's like
this kind of
look
of wisdom and not just like
sort of uh
middle class wisdom or something like
that it's like i have seen some [ __ ]
wisdom
i've seen it all
and on the other side i'm left here
with a pragmatism
and a compassion and also an ability to
cook really well
that's for sure
absolutely
there's just this balance of just deep
intelligence and deep kindness and um
yeah i mean i
uh part
much of who i am is because of the
relationship i had with my grandmother
who is
a um
a russian ukrainian-born
uh russian grandmother
did you learn the russian language i did
it's quite rusty at this point but um
i did uh one of the one of these
wonderful elderly russians in in st
petersburg sort of adopted me i think
that was another thing that a lot of
these elderly women on every side of the
country
kind of adopted me or saw me as this
real curiosity you know it's sort of
just not i mean this was around 2002
2003 it just wasn't common for this sort
of strange american to suddenly show up
in the middle of kumchatka or even saint
petersburg
and just cure absolutely ravenously
curious about everything they had to say
so i often got adopted and
one of them taught me russian and how to
ride a horse um
so the same same babushka taught me both
of those things
and like you said also i i should
mention that there's something about the
soviet education system where yeah
everybody reads tolstoy dostoevsky
it's exceptionally well read no matter
where life has taken you no matter where
you come from
the literature the mathematics the
sciences they're all like
uh extremely well-educated and that
creates
a fascinating
um
populace like
then you take that education that
excellent
early education
and you throw a bunch of hardship at
those people
and then they kind of
um cook in that hardship and come out
really fascinating people on the other
end
um it makes me surprised sort of that
for instance like russian medical
science is not
doesn't you don't see a lot of sort of
studies uh medical studies advancing of
medical science come out of russia which
is sort of i'm surprised sort of i wish
that it would you know i visited academe
goradak outside novosibirsk which is an
entire city the soviets created just for
the study of science and it's like
there's the geology building and there's
the biology building and there's the
chemistry building and
i just feel like russia has this
potential to be a science powerhouse or
even in the medical sciences but
i guess you just i don't see it i'm not
sure why
i mean you can
certainly guess as to why and i
i see the same thing in the other in the
sciences i hold the dearest or in
computer science
in engineering fields
i kind of long held this uh
desire by long i mean last couple years
because a bunch of people reached out to
me
from yandex and moscow state to give
lectures there to sort of connect you
know why why so little science is coming
out of there why so little
um that we hear about
and it feels like we should be able to
bridge the scientific community
like uh
the science
let's even say even in turmoil of
geopolitics even in global conflict i
feel like science should be bigger than
that
um but
why do we not hear from the scientists
is because of the limitations on human
freedoms on scientific freedoms i feel
like in in china
in russia
in
any regime of its sort
you should give freedom to scientists to
to flourish
and to interact with others and you can
only grow from that you shouldn't
suppress that
the sort of cold war ideas
we should put those aside
as a somebody who
spent time in russia as somebody who's
learned russian
do you have some thoughts that you want
to say about the war in ukraine
currently
it's tragic of course um
seemingly pointless to watch the
destruction of a country in real time
um
i guess it's you know when you read
russian history and ukrainian history i
guess it just it's sort of
you know destruction is a big part of it
the populist being beaten down is a big
part of it you know from the
mongolian hordes um
through the tsar and the soviets and
putin i guess
you know it's just
in science in particular medical science
it feels like this sort of unrealized
potential you know the the culture so
beautiful the people are so smart and
well educated i think the word
unrealized potential is kind of how i
feel that's why i wanted to celebrate
that part of the world is there's so
many beautiful people so many brilliant
people
um and i just happen to know the
language so i'm able to appreciate the
beauty of those people
i'm sure the same is true in china i'm
sure that that's one of the things that
makes me sad is there's all these
cultures that
i don't know about i can't fully
appreciate their brilliance even japan
and places like that that are
sort of uh there's channels of
communication wide open and there's a
lot of interaction it's still
not knowing the language i feel like i
miss some of the culture
or portuguese and you know looking at
south america and all that kind of stuff
but anyway in russia there's there
certainly is that unrealized potential
in ukraine
so many brilliant scientists engineers
came from ukraine from russia and i hope
um i hope to get to flourish soon
and i hope we put this
um
i hope we stop this war because all war
is hell
um is there something to comment about
the biology of war
um
is there echoes of the emergency room
experience
um
do you have you have you dealt
with um
with patients that have been touched by
wartime
definitely war and medicine has a very
intricate and complex relationship i
don't know if it was walt whitman who
said it though he was a nurse during the
civil war
that war is the best medical school but
some people have said that um
and
you know even advancements in medicine
are come from war you know the wars in
iraq and afghanistan have in some ways
really revolutionized certain aspects of
the way we treat trauma patients in the
civilian world as well the importance of
tourniquets uh the importance of
transfusing whole blood instead of you
know red blood cells isolated from serum
and platelets etc uh the importance of
pain control in the battlefield that's
changed dramatically everything from
ketamine injections defending the
lollipops in the battlefield
so war has really improved medicine in
many ways
in another way
you know the
department of defense spends a lot of
money on medical research and kind of
really pushes the envelope you know
darpa is a one aspect of the military
budget that really funds these moonshot
experiments that are really fascinating
and to really push
the frontiers more than
seemingly most you know kind of
universities doing
doctors and researchers doing their
research
so in a way you know the space program
which sort of was military initially
then became civilian under nasa also has
led to a lot of advances and
understandings of of health you know on
earth and in space
um so the military's uh or war in
general is a huge way that um
that medicine advances not to mention
the epidemics that come you know um my
grandmother was from what's today
moldova what was then romania she got
typhus during the
during world war ii so there's typhus
outbreaks there's cholera outbreaks you
know all these uh even infectious
disease
things can advance in war which you
wouldn't expect you expect sort of
trauma to be the sort of main problem
but actually infection is a huge problem
throughout history and war so we can
learn a lot it's this kind of horrific
natural experiment in in medical uh care
yeah and i've recently been reading
about some of the horrific medical
experiments performed by
uh nazi scientists nazi germany it's um
i'll talk about it another time perhaps
but
nothing reveals the honesty of human
biology like war
um
just to stay on your wild journeys for a
little bit longer
um you have a tweet about shackleton
saying here's a photo of shackleton's
medical kit from his storied expedition
to antarctica in the 1910s
some perigoric for pain
some laxatives
only the essentials
would you put laxative under the
essentials
anyway sorry to interrupt
when i worked as a ship doctor in
antarctica in 2018 i had a huge cabinet
full of meds and even ekg machine
so
if you can comment sort of on that
contrast first of all your own journey
how harsh was it how difficult was it
and
given that context
can you think about how hard
shackleton's journey was
i think the difference is unimaginably
stark um one thing i do want to point
out is that the use of laxatives early
in the 20th century and before that it
was they were used for a surprising
number of ailments where they probably
did not help at all but
i think that was a holdover from sort of
the old theory of medicine the humoral
theory where you have to balance the
fluids in the body and so causing people
to vomit causing them to have diarrhea
or
purposely taking blood out of them in
bloodletting was a big part and i think
that crazy use of laxatives was um maybe
a holdover from that time
but that being said
they were probably not eating very high
fiber food on that expedition so perhaps
laxatives could have been helpful you
know there's a lot of seal
um
penguin and seal meat being eaten which
is not super high in fiber
so i don't want to discount the
importance of laxatives in that setting
but that wouldn't be the essential thing
if you're thinking
if you're thinking of a tiny kit that
has only the essentials
i mean pain
yes laxatives
maybe not i think the the medical kit
possibilities were much now narrower
back then you know this was um before
antibiotics before
i think germ theory might have been
you know it was known but um there
wasn't much to do about it um so the
availability of medicines i mean that's
something that exploded over the course
of the 20th century so what i can put in
a backpack today filled with modern
medications whether injectable or to be
taken orally is you know just um many
orders magnitude greater than what they
had back then
um so when i i mean when i went my
expedition was nothing like shackleton's
i was on a huge cruise ship um with 160
japanese passengers
who came with their own translators um
and
as i said i had a cabinets not just one
cabinet many cabinets full of
medications both injectable some patches
uh some pills
um i was very impressed actually with
what was available there um and i didn't
have to use a a lot of it thankfully
though i did use some of it for people
um but uh and i i slept and you know i
got free room and board um on the ship
so ev every southern summer cruise ships
go take people to antarctica the
southern atlantic islands like the
falklands and other other parts of the
south pacific and then in the northern
summer the same kind of cruise ship uh
explosion happens you know going to
greenland and iceland and svalbard and
franz josef land and other parts of the
north alaska
so and every ship needs a doctor um so
it's a great opportunity they want
specifically er doctors you know to deal
with emergencies
but uh you're really working in the
middle of nowhere and all you have is
the medications there on the ship and
supplies and your knowledge and
experience and so it's it's a very
different experience than working in a
high-tech modern hospital with every bit
of technology and every sub-specialist
consultant available
but i sort of like that challenge i mean
i like going to the ends of the earth
it's beautiful it's exciting it's
fascinating
um practicing medicine in those settings
is extra challenging and really makes
you hones some of your skills which is
part of the reason that i sought them
out
do you uh see echoes of some of that
same effort i've gotten a chance to
interact with astronauts and those kinds
of folks
working on space missions do you see
some of those same echoes of challenging
efforts going out into space maybe
landing on mars and maybe beginning to
build a small
colony on mars yeah i think the health
care that is needed will be a big part
of that you know obviously we're
probably going to send overall quite
healthy people
but there's a lot of medical decisions
to make about what should be brought
what should be expected you know to some
extent
a lot i've had a lot of doctors say oh
my goodness i can't believe you work in
the middle of nowhere what do you do if
someone you know gets a brain bleed like
falls hits their head needs a
neurosurgeon i mean the obvious answer
is they die you know
things when you're in the middle of
antarctica
things kill you that wouldn't if you're
inside a university hospital that's
fully equipped to help with every
problem that arises
mars takes that to a crazy extreme
obviously
i know that even going to antarctica
different countries have had different
strategies i believe it was australia
used to
kind of just in anticipation remove
people's gall bladders
just so that it wouldn't get inflamed
because that is a very common medical
emergency so they would just remove it
beforehand even though it was not
diseased at all just so that while
they're stuck in antarctica over the
winter for instance
that wouldn't be a problem you know
there's many other issues that can arise
but so those are some decisions to make
maybe the people who go into mars should
have their appendix removed their
gallbladder removed maybe they should
have a cardiac cath to see if they have
coronary artery disease just to know
their chances of getting a heart attack
there though it's not always predictive
you know it's hard to predict who's
going to get a heart attack but
maybe with all the data around today
we'll get you know better at predicting
but that would be a huge part you know
we can't have people the few peop few
pioneers in a mars colony dying of heart
attacks and things like that stuff would
you go
you've gone to some harsh conditions to
be a doctor would you go to mars to be a
doctor
um it would definitely be
amazing i think because i have a wife
and two small children probably not in
the cards for me at this point
but
you humans with your human attachments
sex and death
if you just put more priority on the
death than the sex i think would be
uh
better off
no i would love to go to mars and
actually i you know i practice high
altitude medicine in nepal
space medicine is sort of an extension
of that you know the air is just much
thinner like non-existent you know as
you go higher in the mountains the
things that happen to human physiology
are very bizarre and strange and
still not well explained by science and
in space it's just like a crazy
extension of high altitude
if i could just return to the we didn't
really i think we mentioned a little bit
about the food you had just if you can
high level say what is the greatest meal
you've ever had so your last meal let's
go
if one more meal i get to
uh murder you after this is your last
day we get this planet together where in
the world would you go what would you
eat
i would say the most delicious thing is
bone marrow and i would love a full meal
of bone marrow for my last last dish i
did on my birthday in 2002
ate a kilogram and a half of crab meat
in kamchatka and that was also amazingly
delicious
uh the king crab they have there is
incredible
but
i would go with bone marrow which is um
i think just one of the most delicious
foods and it's sort of this weird body
part you know it's basically all your
stem cells not all of them but the stem
cells that produce all your blood cells
so they are spitting out billions of
white blood cells red blood cells and
platelets every day and there's a bunch
of fat in there as well
just one of the places the body stores
fat and so you basically add heat and
that's all you need it's like the
perfect food you add heat the fat for
frying the stem cells is already there
there's a naturally a bone vessel to
contain it all probably add some flavor
too it's like the perfect food what does
it matter which which uh which animal
i prefer a larger animal just so there's
more of it i actually like well that's
true i actually really like sort of bone
marrow from like chicken bones right
just sucking it out of the bone
yes i'm i'm known for leaving absolutely
nothing edible on the plate except bone
itself there's one other human i know
that loves
um
bone marrow as much as you do and that's
joe rogan
so go
unnatural how much that man loves bone
marrow i understand why i love the steak
part the bone marrow like you know what
let me um
let me argue with you because
i don't know um
it could be an acquired taste but
there's just too much it's like too much
with too little work for it
like it's as if
you gave me lobster meat without the
lobster having to clean the lobster
and i just feel like i'm spoiling myself
there's so it's very fatty it's
i don't know maybe i want to work for
something that tastes like that well if
you start from the whole animal you do
have to work to get at it right a lot of
animals have the um teeth and the jaw
muscles to chomp through bone we do not
so um you know when you buy it from the
store it's already sawed up
but i've definitely gotten marrow out of
deer bones you know with a hatchet just
chop off just chop off the fat end and
start spooning it out or maybe i'll
revisit it that's fascinating and where
where would you eat it
where in which place of the world
is is there something about
who cooks it who you eat it with
um
you're not allowed to pick your family
right
[Laughter]
so like which place in the world rural
or in the city
those kinds of things you've been to so
many fascinating places
i would say i'm antarctica i would say
is one of the most picturesque places
i've ever been i really did not and i
didn't know how mountainous it was and i
guess i knew there'd be the ice but just
i didn't know how much ice it was you
know it's ice and mountains just
overwhelming i just you know as as kind
of overwhelming bone marrow might seem
to you sort of that feast for your eyes
um
and just ice in general is amazing like
the icebergs floating around antarctica
is just astounding like the different
shapes the sizes
are uh incredible there's actually a i
believe it's u.s navy website that
tracks the largest icebergs and you can
read about each of them and how big they
are and just
the formations you see similar up near
green land though i have not been to
greenland um
just ice in general is just amazing so i
could just look at its different forms
while eating bone marrow forever until
you kill me that is yeah and afterwards
we go it's back to the death of the
death and sex i
what is it about the ice is it uh sort
of the enormity of nature it just
reminds you that it's going to be there
before you and after
and then you get to partake in the
eating of the um
the thing you need for maintaining of
your biological
temporary biological organism
yeah i think it's a few things one is
just the shapes that you see you know
the wave action
just eating away at these pieces of ice
you get these arches and just these
shapes i mean it's just like geometry
the geometry alone is amazing i studied
math as an undergrad and i've always
appreciated uh geometry
and just the shapes alone are just look
like brilliant works of modernist art
and just
obviously no two are ever the same
not to mention a lot of them are this
unearthly blue color that is just um
really startling and fascinating the
same color of glaciers
you know in various parts of the world
that blue color is just really amazing
and i also just love how it's sort of
this constant shedding
from our antarctic continent from
greenland you know it's this constant
process of snow falling inland and
pushing the glaciers further out to sea
and them breaking loose i mean obviously
it seems to be happening faster these
days but it's sort of this constant
shedding and sort of i always like
thinking about how the body has
something similar you know we're
constantly shedding and renewing and
rebuilding
everything um and so ice is sort of this
constant similar process
yeah
i did not know you were a math undergrad
so that i mean you're just keep getting
more fascinating
can you maybe take a small step into
that direction
what do you find beautiful about
mathematics why did you journey into
that part of the world for a time
so i liked math i especially liked so
college math i did some calculus in high
school when i got to college math i was
amazed that
there were no more numbers you know the
digits disappeared it was just variables
concepts you know um there was almost no
more numbers at all it was like this
totally abstract
um
you know kind of way of thinking but
that sort of reflects the natural world
and teaches you about the natural world
though it's sort of this perfect you
know platonic ideal perhaps of the
natural world that can still sort of
help explain what happens in the natural
world but
um just these concepts are so abstract
from like
life and from um you know the natural
world and i was actually getting
interested in the natural world at the
same time when i was in um at nyu
studying math you know i took a tour of
central park that was pointing the guy
steve brill was pointing out these wild
edible plants and i was learning to
identify the first plants and knowing
what's edible what's not that was
totally fascinating and sort of this
kind of thing that i felt like was
connecting me to nature and it was
balanced with this
utterly abstract science you know or
early abstract lessons i was getting in
in math class where i was thinking
through series you know as we approach
infinity what happens to these equations
and
concepts of like rings and abstract
algebra i don't know it was just this uh
dichotomy that i i enjoyed both aspects
of yeah
the concepts but so
so different
this kind of logical
rigorous view of the world in the world
of biology
why the big
how did that feel to take the leap into
the
the biological the mushy mess
of the human body from the mathematical
which is all very clean right it does it
does feel like a big step i think
there's more connection than you think
you know we talked about symmetry of the
body earlier
that is a real thing you know fluid
dynamics of how our various bodily
fluids flow and what makes them not flow
as well and what makes them flow better
and
you know
all these different aspects of science
go into the body um
you know everything from hard bone to
softer kind of flesh to liquids
of various consistencies
you know a lot of science does and math
does teach you about kind of how the
body works how it can work better what
happens in sort of disease states
yeah i suppose there's a there's a
connection
there's also kind of a
sort of uh computational biologist this
computational equivalence
of each of the disciplines which are
becoming more and more fascinating with
all the work the deep mind is doing in
the work of genetics all that kind of
stuff simulating different parts of the
body to try to gain an intuition
understanding of it that to me is um
super fascinating but sometimes it does
feel like an over simplification of the
way the body really does it because the
body is is an incredibly weird complex
system
and it finds a way the adaptability the
resilience the redundancy that's built
in
it's it's weird it's
it's and it's incredibly powerful and so
unlike the kind of
uh computer-based systems that we build
at least we engineer in the software
engineering world
which kind of starts to make you think
how can we
engineer computer systems in a different
way that make them more resilient in the
real world that's sort of a robotics
question
what do you think about that
what does it take to build
a humanoid robot or robots that are as
resilient as the human body
how difficult do you think is that
problem having studied the human body
how hard is the engineering problem of
building
systems like that guy over there the
legged
guy that is as resilient as the human
body to the
harsh conditions of the real world
i think it's very hard and we definitely
haven't gotten there yet i think we
could probably learn lessons from people
who are trying to grow artificial organs
in the lab to eventually you know
transplant into people which would solve
the huge problem of needing to get those
organs from others and you know the
rejection of putting a foreign material
inside your body your immune system
tends not to like that
um you know
that has advanced a lot recently i think
i think um
some advances actually have been where
you know we pay a lot of attention to
stem cells stem cell stem cells we can
grow whatever we want out of stem cells
but now there's sort of a recognition
that the what we call the extracellular
matrix which is sort of the you know
foundation of the body the thing that
holds all the cells into their proper
shape and keeps them where they should
be um
that is actually crucial and there's
probably a lot of signaling that goes on
like you stick a stem cell on the right
extracellular matrix it will turn into
the kind of cell that you want and take
the right shape and position and start
functioning
i think that's been a huge uh
huge advance knowing that it's not just
these you know celebrity stem cells that
are the answer it's this kind of
part in the background this sort of just
like laying the foundation the system
that you put these cells onto
and we're not there yet but there's
definitely a lot uh happening a lot of
research happening and i think there'll
be some advances probably soon
so
now on the topic of interaction
of uh computational systems with biology
so if you look at a company like
neurolink or the the whole effort of
brain computer interfaces
now there's a neurosurgery component
there
we have to connect
electrical systems
with biological systems
so just even the implanting is is
difficult
um then the communication is difficult
what would you say from what you know
about the brain what you know about the
human body and all the
the beautiful mess that's there how
difficult is the effort of neural link
do you think it's feasible
i think it's it's definitely feasible i
think there we need to probably know
more than we do um and and know how to
connect it you know in all these ways i
think some advances for instance
you know much less sexy but really
already impacting medical care is
something called deep brain stimulation
which is done for parkinson's disease
and others where
neurosurgeons implant this this device
that electrically stimulates the part of
the brain
that is not functioning in parkinson's
disease and it's quite dramatic how
effective it works and i remember as a
med student watching a neurologist
literally like turn the electricity up
on this handheld thing and you could see
the person's parkinson tremor go away
and you could see them start to walk in
a more steady fashion
and i know there's studies there's
actually studies or
there may be studies in the future
studying the same deep brain stimulation
for
everything from eating disorders to
severe oc like severe ocd like
paralyzing ocd not just like i want to
wash my hands three times but um
and uh so i think the you know the
potential is there but i guess
connecting the brain in a microscopic
way in sort of a multi-faceted way you
know there needs to be sort of a million
connections or some some very high
number of connections for them to work
fluidly as far as i know i'm not an
expert in the area
first of all i i believe and i trust in
the adaptability of the biological
system to whatever crazy stuff you try
to shove in there so it's going to
potentially reject things but it's also
going to if it doesn't reject things
adapt
and if we can create computational
systems that also adapt
ai systems that adapt and can kind of
both of them reach towards each other
and figure stuff out
but actually our current ai systems are
not very adaptable
uh to the what like in in the wild way
that biology is adaptable like adaptable
to anything
and if we can build ai systems like that
i feel like there's some interesting
things you could do but of course
there's ethics
and there's real human lives at stake
and there you can't quite experiment you
have to have things that work and maybe
simulation can help but reality is
it's uh it's a dangerous playground to
play on
it is messy
you tweeted that quote if you look back
from far enough into the future every
doctor today will look like a total
quack
um
first of all that's humbling to think
about
like we don't know what we're doing
in the great like there's been so much
progress
that we kind of have this confidence
that we figured it all out
if you look at history and you read how
people thought
i mean there's so many moments in
history where people
really thought that they figured it all
out it's almost like there's nothing
else left to do
at every stage in history
and uh and then you realize no progress
often happens
like exponentially
and every moment you continue to think
you figured it all out
but if you're being honest if you're
being humble then you realize we're just
shrouded in mystery so what do we make
of this like how should we feel that how
should you feel as a doctor how should
we feel
as scientific explorers
of the human body the fact that we're
probably going to be wrong about
everything we currently know
right there's a saying actually
by the time you finish med school half
of what you learned is wrong
um which is
quite illustrative and
becoming more true as time goes on you
know so much medical research going on
so much learning going on is really
wonderful in a way
but in some ways we still learn these
concepts you know from the past and i
know when you take a test as a medical
student sometimes
you know they want to ask you they want
you to give the old answer but you know
there's a new answer because of recent
science but you know to give the old
answer that's now incorrect to get the
question right on the test that happens
actually quite a bit because things
change so quickly
um yeah you know when i look back at
doctors from centuries past i mean it's
absurd what they were doing to their
patients i mean for probably for most of
human history they were doing more harm
than good you know they're draining
people of their blood uh that was you
know bloodletting was a huge part of
of medical care
you know um
george washington died of a
peritonsillar abscess an abscess right
next to the tonsil which has the great
name of quincy and they bled him to
death you know i mean kind of adding
insult to injuries doctors are menace
and do a lot of harm i mean hopefully
not intentionally you know even medical
errors are still a huge problem cause of
death and morbidity
so we do a lot of things that are not
great but you know our knowledge yeah
it's it's very imperfect at this point i
do have some confidence you know i guess
perfect scientific studies that try to
get at the reality of the universe are
essential because when i think
of why a certain medication works for a
certain condition it might make perfect
sense in my head knowing the biology the
biochemistry the anatomy it makes
perfect sense it must work i gave it to
the patient they got better and that's
happened 20 times in the last year
but it's you know i'm wrong like when
you actually do a study it actually
doesn't help maybe it hurts
um and that's really i think the way we
explain
medications working in our minds is
often wrong when you end up finally
doing the
the study and some of the most
interesting experiments um involve what
we call sham surgery so for instance
people who injure their knee you know
arthroscopy where an orthopedic surgeon
goes in there with a scope
gets bits of bone out shaves down the
cartilage you know cleans things up and
it helps some people but they they
actually did some studies where one
group of people got the true arthroscopy
and others just got sham surgery where
they put them to sleep made little cuts
in the skin so they woke up with scars
and then it turned out that it's not
clear arthroscopy's actually helping
and the same there was a recent
huge
study of doing putting a stent in
someone's coronary arteries if they have
stable chest pain not like i'm having a
heart attack you need a stent like right
then but you know kind of chronic
coronary artery disease where every time
i run up the stairs i get chest pain and
then when i rest it goes away
like obviously you put a stent you
increase blood flow to the heart like
how could that not work but then when
they did the sham catheterization it
actually looks like it might not
actually
help better than the sham
so i think those placebo-controlled
studies are essential i mean it is
shocking and this has been driven home
during the last two years
how hard it is to figure out what the
hell's going on in the universe and with
especially with our bodies like it is
really hard to get at the truth and what
you think makes sense like often turns
out i mean his the history of modern
medicine is littered with examples where
it made perfect sense and it seemed to
help some patients and it turns out
it's not doing anything or it's harmful
yeah there's all kinds of narratives
swimming around we convinced ourselves
as a human civilization that something
is true
there's uh propaganda machines there's
just self-delusion
there's uh
centralized communities
like there's a scientific community that
believes a certain thing there's the
conspiracy theories that believe a
certain thing
sometimes the scientific community
writes sometimes the conspiracy theories
uh theorists are right throughout human
history i mean and we now think the
scientific community well now the
science has really figured it out we're
way smarter than we were in the past and
then there's these like interesting
studies
that i've seen i think uh roman hanson
mentioned to me
that if you look at the entirety of
medication
like the effect of medication on human
health if you do those kinds of broad
studies
does it actually help
like does quality of life lifespan
certain measures of the well-being
does if you and you look at human
society as a whole
does taking medication or not actually
help and those studies find there's no
positive or negative effect with
medication
and there that's a very kind of uh
interesting perspective that means
you could probably argue uh
you know a lot of ways but the point is
uh because you can bring up
literally a billion cases where
medication has significant positive
impact on a particular patient but you
have to kind of zoom out
and honestly look at the positive
effects of medicine
um of lifestyle choices diet choices of
uh exercise or not you know maybe we'll
find a venture that exercise is actually
bad for you
but maybe like there there's all kinds
of things that we're going to um
uh i feel like we're going to figure out
one of the things i think we're going to
figure out
everything i've learned about my body
is that
aside from it being adaptable there's a
lot of very unique parameters
that are opaque to me
that i'm measuring through this feedback
mechanism by trying stuff and learning
about it
and
one of the things we might learn is that
medicine cannot be done
without collecting a huge amount of data
about each individual human so like it's
absurd
to be like if i show up
uh
and see a doctor it's absurd for that
doctor to have just a couple of minutes
with me
like with just
like looking at basic symptoms looking
at
such like
crappy uh data like first of all no
long term data
no longitude no data
no historical data no
detailed analysis of all the possible
things not just the related to your
symptoms but related to other things
that you're not complaining about just
giving you a full picture of the data
and then using ai
to help the human doctor highlight the
things that you should
perhaps pay extra attention to i think
we'll look back at this time is
ridiculous that doctors will expect it
to help anybody whatsoever without
having the data without having a huge
amount of data about the human body like
you're you have to do so much with so
little data
it's very 19th century it's very 19th
century so it relies on the brilliance
of doctors and of course
the intuition the instinct you build up
over time right and that's quite
powerful the human brain is pretty
pretty damn good
for using experience to teach you how to
make good decisions but still it's it's
uh
it's you might as well be bloodletting
like
it's humbling to think about that it's
humbling it is humbling and it's
important i think doctors sometimes lose
that uh
humble
perspective on what they do and i think
it's very important because as i said
you know medical history is just medical
dogma has been tossed into the trash bin
so many times something doctors were
sure of was the case is not
and it's important to um
to be cognizant of that
um you tweeted
about somebody that
had a
big impact just by reading about him on
my life as well
i still think about him
uh rest in peace dr paul farmer a big
inspiration to me his medical career was
a testament to what one person can do to
improve the world
so who was paul farmer and what made him
a great doctrine a great man and
somebody who was an inspiration to you
so
paul farmer
was a kind of pioneer of global health
he um started
partners in health which is a kind of an
international health organization that
operates it originally in haiti also
rwanda and elsewhere
and i think he was just so
a zealot for getting health care to some
of the poorest people in the world and
he i remember reading some of his books
and a book about him by tracy kidder
that's really great mountains beyond
mountains
about how even when he was a medical
student he was flying back and forth to
haiti in between exams and just
with this really intense uh focus and
interest in in getting healthcare to
where it's where it's not and i think
traveling around the world especially to
poorer places like india calcutta nepal
you really see how unevenly the benefits
of modern medicine are spread over the
surface of the earth not only if you're
because if you're in antarctica and have
a heart attack you're in serious trouble
but um you know just medications that
cost pennies a day um can help people
you know a lot of children in india
under five die of diarrhea
and all they need is oral rehydration
solutions to
uh to stay hydrated you know most of
them can't afford iv fluids for instance
to get admitted to the hospital and
really dehydration just kills
hundreds of thousands of kids throughout
the world
not to mention
bacterial pneumonia also is a major uh
cause of death in children under five
and many of them not all would be saved
by amoxicillin which is just pennies
um and i for me you know i i took a
had a path and i wanted to have a career
in global health and i started traveling
abroad to india and elsewhere when i was
a medical student and i continued doing
that paul farmer was sort of one of the
first to kind of open everyone's eyes i
think about
the good you can do with just
money that we would you know change that
we would throw away just you know put in
a person forget it or wherever we
accumulate change these days um so
that's very eye-opening um and while
medical science advances and that's good
you know we shouldn't forget that
hundred-year-old treatments could save
lives in parts of the world where
they're just not available people should
definitely read mounds beyond mountains
just um
for me at least sort of a person from
outside all of it
it was
the first person to make me realize how
difficult
and the amount of humanity that's
involved in being a doctor
so it's not some kind of cold
economics-based argument about where to
send treatments and so on
that is there too like you said
basic treatments can help
hundreds of thousands millions of people
in many parts of the world but
it's also
when you have a patient in front of you
there's some aspect of you that's
willing to to give a lot of your time a
lot of your money a lot of your effort
to uh saving them
even though it doesn't make any sense
it's uh it's irrational in some sense
but it's also human and that's the
struggle of every doctor like when you
have to choose how to allocate your time
how to allocate your mental energy
right it's a tough it's a tough choice
that a doctor has to make and it's a
human choice it's not
some kind of cold
game theoretic choice it's also a human
choice and it can be
irrational in some sense right people
are asking you for help that's basically
what every patient interaction is
someone's asking you for help so
your inclination is to help them and
even if it means going above and beyond
you know i mean
a lot of factors
affect how compassionate a doctor might
be in any given day or you know point in
their career
their own stress and burnout etc
but it's someone asking you for help and
so you do what you can to help them
you've done
quite a lot of things in your life it's
an interest it's been an interesting
journey and of course there's a lot of
story yet to be written
but what advice would you give to young
people today in high school maybe
undergrad college starting out on that
journey
maybe trying to pick majors trying to
pick
uh jobs careers
dreams and goals they can pursue what
advice would you give them to have a
career they can be proud of or to even
have a life they can be proud of
well i think um
having passion which isn't always a
voluntary thing you know you just have
it or you don't perhaps but
becoming passionate about something and
following it uh no you know wherever it
takes you i think is really important um
you know when i i finished college and
sort of went to russia for the first
time that was in some ways the beginning
of my whole career and
passions in my life and um
i didn't know what i was going for what
was going to happen what kind of career
it would turn into what kind of job
would it help me get when i got back i
wasn't thinking about any of that i was
i'm very fortunate i got that
opportunity
i was very fortunate to you know be able
to go and see those places and have my
mind opened and i think that really just
the fuel from that uh passion that was
created during that time is still 20
years later going strong
you know i'm partial to health care i
love being a doctor i think it's
the perfect combination of kind of
intellectual problem solving being a
detective while also working with your
hands you know when you do procedures
especially in the er it's sort of the
perfect combination
i'm not a surgeon but i do use my hands
quite a bit um whether you know
for a variety of reasons and so i always
loved working with my hands i loved
crafts especially prehistoric crafts
before medical school and i just love
kind of problem solving getting clues
figuring out what's going on you know
following your nose
using your instincts your knowledge and
also just keen observation of the
patient you know after seeing patient
after patient hundreds of patients maybe
thousands over years you do get this
sort of
innate kind of sense this just dalt
about what might be going on and you
know it's not always a numbers thing
that's the thing there's always
there's gestalt is actually a big part
of medicine you know you often in ers or
in hospitals hear a nurse or doctor say
something like this patient just doesn't
look good and it's sort of you can't
point to a number a value a level in
their blood you know a test
but something about them and i a lot of
that i think has to do with the color of
their skin believe it or not um which
can change and in certain disease states
but i think that uh
it's just
medicine combines this observation uh
the skills the knowledge
it's art and science it's human
and it's robotic you know algorithmic at
the same time and i think it just uh
yeah combines kind of all my passions
all in one and i would you know if
anyone's going into health care i would
strongly encourage them to do so but i'm
very biased so with that early passion
whatever that little flame was that uh
brought you to russia
were you able to vocalize it or was it
just something like a gut that pulled
you towards some
exploration of the unknown or something
like this
i think it was a combination of things
one was just going to a different place
that was different from where i grew up
you know
the suburbs you know when you're in high
school you hate them later on they don't
seem so bad but um you know i just
wanted to get i mean i'm very fortunate
how i was raised and um never wanted for
anything that wasn't rich but just to
get out and see a different place a
different people with a different
culture and history and language and
literature and to see different climates
and geographies and ecosystems i just
wanted to see something different
and that
i guess that's what i've you know sought
after ever since so just that was just
so fascinating like my trip to kamchatka
in 2003
where i was there for four months and um
i didn't speak english for i think two
months out of it and just i remember
lying on the floor some wooden floor in
a hunter's cabin in the middle of
northern kamchatka just being like
what am i doing here this is i'm just so
grateful for like the experiences i was
having what i was seeing and realizing
and learning it was just i was so
grateful even though i was lying on this
hard uncomfortable floor it's just like
this is so amazing
and that i don't think i'll ever have
another travel as meaningful and
life-changing as that particular trip to
genjaka was
um
though i'm still striving after it you
know you never replicate that first high
but you always try um so i just think
that seeing something different is kind
of the game and there wasn't really a
plan because i got a chance to talk to
the ceo of qualcomm recently
and
he
his advice is
always have a plan
and it sounds like
you're saying
uh don't have it don't have a plan
don't need to have a plan
just listen to your gut your passion and
follow that and see see where that takes
you because it's telling you something
yeah i think you know i guess the plan
could be specific or could be as general
as i just want to go far away and see
something very different that's my plan
and i did just one line it just followed
my nose um from one thing to the next
just being interested following my
passion and again very fortunate i could
do that
are there places in the world you're
kind of
thinking about that
your life might take you at some point
just um
to be a doctor there for a time
to explore for a time
that you haven't yet you know i have
some colleagues who do kind of global
health work in various countries in
africa and central and south america
i would really love to
go to some of those places not just for
a short trip but hopefully for an
extended period of time
with sort of the healthcare being the
ticket in um but then maybe even
bringing my children or just you know i
guess at this point
some of the travel i dream about is sort
of replicating what i did and showing it
to my kids in a way
um but there's still a lot i haven't
seen and would love to see as well but
um i think those opportunities sort of
lend themselves well um you know
as a doctor with kind of the ability to
go there and sort of help but help
patients but also teach medical students
and residents um teaching is actually a
huge part of being a doctor that's um
underappreciated but that's actually
part of the fun of being a doctor is
that you're also a teacher of course the
word doctor means teacher but um it's
come to mean something else
um but uh you know i in some of my jobs
i'm working alongside medical students
and residents and i'm giving them my
knowledge my wisdom sharing with them
stories and so that's a very uh
satisfying part of the job
if we can take a brief step into uh a
dark place
together for a time
is there um
what is a dark place you've
gone in your mind in your life
what would be
the darkest place you ever gone
for time
for a moment
um
and how did you survive how did you
overcome it
that's a very good question i i would
say um
i haven't had as dark moments as many of
the people who i care for in the
emergency room i'm fortunate in that way
i've had a pretty you know
enjoyable satisfying life
you know i think everybody
um has dark moments though including me
one of the most shocking things i feel
like
becoming an adult my two big
realizations have been one no one knows
what they're doing and two
suicide is incredibly common like in in
all humans in all societies and that i
just find shocking i mean i've never
seriously contemplated myself but
i wouldn't say it hasn't crossed my mind
during some more stressful um times of
life
um
i think it crosses everyone's mind and
sort of as a kid i found that i never
would have guessed how common suicide is
it's an important question to
sort of the uh the camus question like
why live
why
why
because like life especially when you're
struggling
especially when life is [ __ ]
like why am i doing any of this
and then on top of that chemistry of
your brain
it could be as simple as diet and
nutrition and
aforementioned exercise and things like
this that affect the chemistry such that
you're more predisposed to go to the
places
of asking the question why
and maybe um struggling to find a good
answer
because it's actually a question with no
good answer except
something in your chemistry says well i
kind of like it
but there's no good intellectual answer
and especially if day to day it's pain
you get to see these stories of um you
know robin williams
these people that are on top of the
world from an external perspective but
from an internal perspective
it's struggle every day is pain
it feels hopeless and
yeah that's a that's a question we all
have to struggle with or learn how to
ignore maybe because if you ask the
question too much you're not gonna
you're not going to find a good answer
that's a choice you make i personally
think you should ask that question a lot
um
but maybe because i have the luxury of
the chemistry i have where i'm not in
danger
of uh seriously contemplating suicide
but why liv is an important question to
answer constantly and struggle to answer
that constantly
but people i am uh i've gotten uh i've
been extremely fortunate
to meet people
over the past couple of years that are
really struggling
and
you have probably met
people who are really struggling
like orders of magnitude more people who
are really struggling
some of it is psychological a lot of it
is biological
and man life life is a [ __ ]
it's pretty tough very true
i do think also past trauma is a plays a
big role there like we talked about um
you know war wounds and ptsd and
a lot of people grew up
i mean which is horrific childhoods
they're abused in one way or another and
i think a lot of people who have not not
a major i'm not saying a majority but a
lot of people for instance who i see in
the er
uh coming in for threatening suicide or
actually trying and failing and being
brought to the er you know a lot of them
just have really traumatic experiences
um you know saw their parent commit
suicide uh were abused you know these
leave scars in the in the human brain
and mind and a lot of the sub their
subsequent lives of whether it's
substance abuse alcoholism etc is almost
trying to escape from their own memories
and
it's sort of such this overwhelming um
battle sometimes like sometimes
people get ruined it seems and just
can't be fixed you know what i mean yes
you can improve diet and health and your
life choices and
seek out your passion and exercise and
those definitely will help but sometimes
just like you know you bear the scars of
the past and there's no getting rid of
them
yeah
i think it's possible to live with them
i think there's a struggle i would never
say give up you know um keep fighting
it is a constant it can be a constant
battle for some people i know it can be
and i've talked to
many of those folks i know it can feel
hopeless but
keep up the good fight
hopelessness the good fight hopelessness
is kind of one of the big suicide risk
factors that you sort of ask about as a
as a doctor you know do you feel
hopeless and that sort of uh
can be a harbinger
i have uh quite a few dark moments so if
you if you if you're listening
and you're struggling
we're in this together brother and
sister keep up the good fight
um
life is a [ __ ] as you said
it's it's really harder i think as a kid
you know in a joy-free childhood you
don't realize like obviously there's a
ton you don't realize about life but
then when you get to be an adult you
realize just how complex and hard it is
is it this hard for adult animals i
don't know i don't think it is
um
so having
seen the honesty of biology before you
do you think about your own death
do you
contemplate death are you afraid of your
own death how do you make sense of it
definitely thought about it especially
maybe while doing certain risky things
um ice climbing and others where every
time i look down i thought about my own
death but um
i think
you know i think having kids changes the
equation for sure
um
should change the equation perhaps so i
think a lot of
now when i think about what will happen
when i die you know there's a lot of um
worrying about what will happen to the
people i care for you know you think
about things like insurance policies
like life insurance and you know yes
disability insurance that's not related
to death but more just injuries and
that's part of the weight i guess that
um you know you feel as an adult um that
i think grows rapidly when you have kids
though not only you know there's other
people you can care for your own parents
and loved ones like a lot of people
depend on
individuals and so you think about what
will happen to the other people when you
die
but also
to push back
that weight
might be something
you've convinced yourself to think about
it's an important way to think about
but you focus on that way
to escape the other
weight
which is
that's
one point
this consciousness just comes to an end
and it's hard to make sense of
of that
we kind of delude ourselves and thinking
okay it just yeah it's ends that's the
natural way of things and so on that
makes sound so we're good okay that's
the way that's the way of life but like
i don't think it's like cognitively
easy to just realize how
terrifying that is
we we we love life so much
that
the end of it
it just um
it's something that makes no sense
and if you linger on that thought i
think it's a painful it's a it's a
painful i would say even terrifying
thought
not scared of like uh in a way that's
almost like philosophically terrifying
like it just reminds you maybe humbles
you that you don't know any of the
anything about anything
but one of the things we do as humans
really well is we uh especially with
kids
you realize okay we start caring for
others in the community and the family
and so on and that distracts us because
then we can at least focus on other
people's problems and not deal with our
own
uh
when i was a medical student i was
particularly fascinated with kind of
what actually happens as people die like
in the last minute seconds of life it's
sort of surprising sometimes like what
actually kills people you know like um
you can get a let's say a bad head
injury and you know what kills you
sometimes it's just
your consciousness decreases and you
become
kind of comatose you aspirate
your oxygen plummets and you get cardiac
arrest you know that kind of sequence of
events
or
you know a heroin overdose
let's say you stop breathing similarly
your oxygen goes down then you get a
cardiac arrest so i was really
fascinated with what actually happens
what makes people die
and it was sort of a
morbid fascination obviously like most
of med school is
and i had many instances where
i've had patients pass um and as a
medical student i was sort of
sort of learning what's actually
happening watching it happen and you
know not always always being able to
prevent it it was sort of a scientific
uh exploration then the patient's family
comes in and are just devastated and
then it's like
rips you out of this scientific
perspective and you just
realize how horrible death is but the
person's fine you know it's the family i
guess and that's why
um it's always i guess that pointed out
just how what people leave behind is
often kind of the horribleness of death
like just becoming unconscious and
staying that way doesn't seem
i guess to me personally so bad sort of
like going to sleep not waking up
not counting the pain and stuff that
precedes it so the actual pain the
actual suffering is often felt by the
people who love the person who died
right so both financial pain
psychological pain
for years missing them all those kinds
of things right never forgetting the
anniversary of their death you know just
having flashbacks or something reminding
you
that sort of
brought home to me sort of what death
means and it was more about what
people leave behind than what happens to
them specifically see i like
those concerns because i feel like i can
do
a lot about those those make sense to me
then just be if you're a father just be
a good father
uh
if you're sort of you mentioned some
insurance yeah there's like financial
stuff to take care of what i don't know
what to do with
is is uh the philosophical excellent
existential crisis of the fact that this
freaking thing ends
it doesn't like i don't
know how to deal with the mystery that's
beyond death
why are we here why are we born at all
what is consciousness and you just look
at yourself what is this why do i have
the capacity to suffer
um
why why all these kinds of why questions
that don't have answers speaking of
which let me ask you a why question
the biggest ridiculous one what do you
think is the meaning of life
having with this book studied
the incredible beautiful biology of life
this the components the engineering
components they make up this human body
but when you look at the entirety of it
what is why
why are we here sometimes probably more
often than not feel like the question of
why is a trick of the human brain and
and outside of our thoughts there is no
why
why is not a something that's in the
universe it's just this trick happening
inside our brain
um so what why is a game that the human
brain plays on itself and then
the reality of
life doesn't have wise i do wonder if
asking why is sort of an evolutionary
adaptation like um
why you know maybe hunting gathering why
does this plant grow there and not there
why do i see the same deer tracks and by
the same tree every three days what you
know why is this why is that
um
why does this plant uh make me vomit and
that plant doesn't i guess those y's are
very practical and oriented towards
survival
but then obviously you know we
not only use why you know we use it to
maybe hunt better gather better survive
better but then we sort of extrapolated
into these
unanswerable questions you know
um about why like why does life exist
and it's possible that they're not
unanswerable in the long arc of science
and history it's we're just striving for
the really difficult questions right now
we just
don't know much about anything and so
we're striving but there there's long
so most of human history you were asking
why questions for which we now have
very precise answers
including with biology and physics and
all those kinds of things
and maybe the whys this cutting edge of
science of the explorer of the curiosity
of the human mind
like man's search for meaning is the
sort of
the ultimate driver of the why
and it's almost like it could be an
evolutionary adaptation of asking
exceptionally hard-wired questions
that will never get answered
like so you should always have like it's
like a cue it's a it's a stack of
questions why questions and that thing
should never come to the bottom
should always be striving and that's
that's useful for humans to come up with
better and better ways of survival
and uh maybe
from in a bigger perspective for the
universe to figure out something about
itself and it's just humans just a
useful tool for that
or life on earth as a useful tool for
that well
john this your your uh
[Music]
for people who should know you're from
philadelphia i'm from philadelphia so
it's an it's an honor that you would
travel all this way from a place i love
to the new place i love
and uh that you will write this really
incredible book that celebrates the
human body in the most honest of ways
and uh thank you for everything you do
for being a great educator for being a
great doctor for being a great person
and for spending your really valuable
time with me today thank you john thanks
for having me lex
thanks for listening to this
conversation with jonathan reisman to
support this podcast please check out
our sponsors in the description
and now let me leave you with some words
from paul farmer the doctor who has
inspired both jonathan and me with the
way he practiced medicine and the way he
lived his life
the idea that some lives matter less
is the root of all that is wrong
with the world
thank you for listening and hope to see
you next time
you